it's no my knight wouldn't be able to
cause a check on the king
um
i
i where can his bishop go to as well try
to press it and you'll notice
his bishop
yours yours this one okay
why do i feel like i don't
oh my god how do i not see that
that is so crazy i don't know why this
is a check and like you're giving up the
bishop but you take the queen
okay
i see what you mean so now he has to
solve it okay he goes there yeah so this
is called discovery check remember yeah
[Music]
oh gee okay okay let's go back because i
did some really random moves okay let's
go back
um
uh okay so in this position
which pieces are either on the same file
or same diagonal or same like or
horizontal vertical whatever so in order
to
cause that i would have to do that right
and then yes okay but but here
here's the thing i don't think you did
it for the right reason wait
well no no no because so here's what i'm
thinking i'm thinking that i need to get
to this point right here right with my
bishop
so
i'd lose a trade though so now i know
why it's the wrong reason
so he would go there i would go
there he takes visualize visualize it so
the night is gone
pawn takes and then
ah partakes
okay so
imagine the night is gone
it's gone
yeah and then i can't do anything with
my queen
i mean i could use my bishop
i have another bishop
so if that pawn is gone but it's on a
different tile
i really don't see it i really don't see
it okay let me move it let me move it
okay
uh okay
can you see it now
no i actually don't know
i don't see it
i do not
oh my gosh like because look if i go
there you take so you're you totally
want me to see something else like the
other pieces check the other pieces
oh my god the queen oh my god
okay so let me go back and see this then
because i really need so was this the
point or was it right here
here here okay so he moves his queen
there
um okay and i've okay so there's one
thing separating between us so what i
want to do is i need to make sure we
remove that in order to remove that i
would go there
he would
oh and it's defended too so if i go
there he doesn't necessarily have to
take but if he takes that or sorry if he
takes that then i take oh my god it's a
win-win
okay
now i see it
that's you're like 200 iq like i was
like i don't yeah i hope i can see that
that's good it's so fun did you like you
wanted to do this for the for like
another reason i was like oh no
yeah oh my god i said yes this is great
but then i realized it's probably for
like something like this
yeah and then i would lose that too
it's really funny it's really funny but
yeah basically this is the move and
they're you're attacking their queen so
i basically have to move my queen and
what would you do then um
so
i could take your rook which i think
would be a good trade you would take my
my knight or you would do that
um otherwise
if i oh if i move the bishop here
i am applying pressure to that piece but
that's the only piece in which case he
could move
um
okay wait a second
so if i move
no
i'm definitely whenever you see material
just take it no need to look for that i
mean unless you see checkmate or like a
better move but if you see okay material
you take it and uh well you get rid of
this piece
okay so very good i think up until now i
mean it's good enough i feel like like
we don't need to go further but it's
like
um i think you can do it regarding the
opening i think this is how he kind of
plays okay um you should be fine just i
hope what you need to focus on um is
stick to the opening rules so do you
remember like the opening rules like by
heart um i didn't know that there was
opening rules the opening rules i know
all right don't move f uh to three f
three so in my case is it c
c three
or is it it's always going to be good so
i wouldn't move there or sorry i would
have moved my pawn there
um i want to make sure to check for
pieces that are far far away like
diagonals and stuff um
like queens yeah uh i want to make sure
not to create any islands with my pawns
if i can avoid it so i want to use my
knights and bishops
uh get to the center uh i want to
develop my pieces uh castles yes
these are the three rules of the opening
so that you have like a solid opening uh
set up okay so the three girls are once
again control the center with your pawns
uh develop your pieces the knights out
bishops out and then finally you castle
and
that's like how you build up a healthy
position can we do another one i don't
know if you if you want to do another
one but if you want to do of course i
just don't know if you still have time i
don't know when you have to join their
call or something yeah i'm keeping an
eye on it i'm looking at the discord and
i'm good for now okay okay okay great so
what i was thinking is
um i'd be white this time and then
you like
yeah and i would love for you to try to
like prevent me from developing my
pieces because i feel like that's what
happens a lot when i'm playing regular
matches i don't know why
but well the thing is i don't think that
will happen today okay okay
i'll try i'll try to turn it off i'll
just try this time i'll just try this
one uh just so you get a sense of it
let me try
um
let me try to do something else it's
anna maya um a-n-a-a-n-n-a-m-a-j-a
okay
so uh i would honestly
just
get my knight so you so what you're
going to do is you push here but i don't
think that'd be
i feel like i should counter that to get
center
um
remember where this bishop goes to
oh
okay so i can't go there yeah it's
blocking right okay i mean it's not a
bad move i'm just i just want you to
know that this is not a move i'm
considering okay okay
hmm
my chat says you're a great teacher
okay so
thank you
i have a night that i could take there
but i'm not gonna do that
um
i'm gonna def i'm gonna keep developing
my pieces and i can castle
oh i blocked my pawn actually so now i
can get my bishop out
yeah that's gonna be a little difficult
so whenever that is the case try to just
play it safe and like you can develop
the bishop elsewhere okay so is there
anything wrong with a move like this
then actually no it's perfectly fine
because i cannot push this so okay you
should be good cool um
[Music]
okay let me
do
this what would you do so you're looking
to make this play in which case i can do
that i would win that trade for now so i
feel like i don't need to worry about it
and actually i was going to do this
anyway to develop my bishop um to get it
over here so that works and now i'm
defending
so d3 is a great move like that is what
you're supposed to be doing okay but in
this situation there is um
something you might want to consider
oh
boy
okay
so if i move this here i would be
defending that so if he takes i take
and then i could
no oh i didn't mean to do that
so remember this bishop like what is it
looking at so it's looking at all of
these pieces
right there yeah
yeah
um so if i move my knight here
targeting right now
would oh sorry i think you disconnected
a bit
oh uh what is it targeting right now
targeting the pawn and then the right
the king
right so it is only defended by the king
how i accidentally
became the biggest
chess streamer of all time me
how is that possible
[Music]
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
[Music]
don't worry
i'm down here
guys uh
i saw you big man hey yay
[Music]
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what wait what
i want a refund
can i stop my wife
and as much cash as you can carry you
can keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken
paul champs competitor here
oh my god
[Music]
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knights move
at the angle you stepping up the mag
[Music]
welcome everyone to pog champs for we
have three super exciting matches for
you guys today but first i'm joined by
the one and only grand master daniel
naraditsky daniel how are you feeling
today
hi alexandra hi everybody i'm i'm
feeling great uh this is my first time
commentating in park jams four i've been
following it so closely i'm very very
excited
i have i always get this feeling that
the games are going to be super
interesting and super suspenseful but
it's really a pleasure to be
commentating i know no better way to
spend my wednesday afternoon
absolutely and speaking of the people
who make the games indiv interesting
let's check out the participants today
donya are there any participants you're
super excited to see from the ones we
have here so far
well of course uh seeing ludwig mr beast
box box a couple of these players are
quite experienced and i love seeing them
return
uh you know they're thirsting for blood
and some of them have been exceptional
of course box box is playing today but
it's also great to see all of these new
players and some of them have acquitted
themselves incredibly well uh given the
pressure that all of these players feel
we have nick a30 we're gonna see him
today
uh tech tone as well rubius he's
returning so lots of interesting faces
alexandra and uh i can't wait to jump
into the games today
yeah absolutely and nick a30 will be
making his debut today so i'm really
interested in that game since we don't
have a lot of information and i know
that he's been playing chess as of two
days ago but for those of you that are
just joining in if you missed
yesterday's matches we have the coinbase
rewind for you to recap the best moments
from the day
okay
oh
okay if you go there to the queen to
sheboygan wisconsin don't do it okay
carla don't okay
oh well gg
god damn it
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god
this
is she could just take it
he just forced her
to see maybe a winning move let's get
the double look
okay
what am i talking what am i doing
[Music]
in your eyes
oh my god she has mate on here oh she
thinks she's in check she thinks she's
in check oh my gosh
she think that she'll know oh no
he gets the rook
he's gonna win now
and he suddenly woke up to his clock
look at him almost pre-moving
it's me oh it's mate
oh my god he found a way to win the rook
he found a way to win the rook
this is so crazy
[Music]
oh my god
that's how we feel too
nothing like seeing highlights from the
previous matches to get you excited for
the three we have today starting off
with group c tech tone versus nick a30
dania what are your thoughts on the
first matchup
you know i think it's going to be close
we'll get into this once the game begins
uh techtone he played in in tournament
r2 so he's a little bit more experienced
and nick 830 i believe he's making his
uh debut today as you indicated uh super
excited about that we know the players
they have millions of youtube subs and
twitch subs uh but you know
everybody mr b sludwig they all get
nervous uh when it's their first time
playing fox gym so super excited for
that one alexandra
yeah absolutely and their ratings are
also super close a hundred elo within
each other it's going to be super
competitive just like harry mack versus
justin minx since they're both extremely
new to chess
and that's always the most entertaining
games when the level is very close
between both participants
yeah i think they're really going to be
thinking outside the box or shall i say
thinking outside the box box oh hey look
uh voxbox is playing today he's going to
be rounding off today against sapnap and
obviously alexander he is the favorite
he's very experienced he's the fearsome
competitor
uh he's done so well in pogchamps but
sapnap is uh he's not gonna be napping
during that game okay i'm just gonna
stop i've missed your puns so much tanya
i i want to get a pun counter for today
and yeah 30
i hope i hope i hope we're going to get
in the triple digits okay let's see what
you can do today
sounds great
for everybody watching this is also a
tournament that is supporting an
incredible cause chess.com is happy to
be supporting rise above the disorder in
their cause to remove the two greatest
barriers to mental health care access
and affordability started by a world of
warcraft guide leader in 2013 rise above
the disorder has helped tens of
thousands of people all over the world
receive mental health care free of
charge go to chess.com
rad to make a donation and remember
chess.com will be matching up to a
hundred thousand dollars of the
community's contributions so your
donation can go a long way and another
thank you to the other sponsor pogchamps
is presented by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered visit
coinbase.com chess and get five dollars
in bitcoin when you sign up and verify
your account donnie are you gonna do do
your sign up there
hey i already have a coinbase account uh
it's great
and um
hey um
that's some awesome motivation so thank
you big thank you to to our sponsors and
well the games are about to start
alexandra so everybody better have their
seat belts buckled
absolutely chat we are going to take a
quick break we'll be right back with the
first game tech done versus nick a30
don't go anywhere
vile evil cat all right let's uh
let's warm up with some um
with some three minute chests real quick
all right yeah one minute
shut up
[Music]
bro i'm telling you you just let me go
first i will clap your cheeks
every goddamn time
yeah now you don't know what's the
thing
go ahead hit it
yep classic what the what are you
gonna do with that huh go take it
take it
thanks
now what the are you gonna do
nothing you're going to do nothing
you're gonna take the what's good i take
you back the
what is this mickey mouse one for one
what are you gonna do
you can take there go for it take it
take the i don't even want her
take the
back the up
clown yeah you're damn right oh you put
me in check wow
i'm pissing myself go ahead take it a
day off of twitch is very ill thought
out twitch get reduced server costs and
all the missing subs simply arrive the
next day or auto renew
it's pointless
smudge
you
oh i thought i called him with his
pants down dude
that's so sad that's cool gigantic
that's so sad the eat it
goodbye queen
you didn't notice again are you dumb bro
have you played this game
oh
well i'm gonna lose on time again
that's unlucky yeah you do hate to see
it
[Music]
yeah you do hate to see it
you do really hate to say it enjoy dude
yep
take it
that's right you won't
you gonna do
better go hungry hungry hippos on your
ass oh
okay
excellent laura fault excellent
excellent play excellent play
oh my god a chess legend
dude just you wait when i pull when i
eventually pull my that's the thing
right the the problem that i have with
chess is that you got to play like 18
000 years to be good at it
right
you got to play like 18 000 years
and the problem is i don't have 18 000
years to play you know what i
mean
like for me
i got like a minute a day tops
congratulations but at the end of the
day
it is what it is
yup
bingo
bango
now you don't know what the to do
we are back a quick reminder before we
get into the format that the best way to
stay up to date on all pogchamps
happenings is to follow us on your
favorite social media channels and
especially our discord because right now
you can join our pogchamps discord
channel to tell us who you're rooting
for in pogchamps 4. our sponsor coinbase
will be giving out diamond memberships
that's right free diamond memberships
during the tournament two members of the
pogchamps channel so don't miss out on
this as well as the awesome discussions
prizes use command contest and join for
your chance at a diamond membership at
chess.com now let's get into the format
donya why don't you start us off
absolutely so as many of you already
know players are split into four groups
each of which consists of four players i
really like the time control it's not
too slow not too fast ten minutes with a
five second increment per move so five
seconds is added to
uh each clock after a move is made
there's three points for a win outright
two points for a win that involves tie
breaks one point for a loss and tie
breaks and zero for losing both of the
games uh the top two players advance the
championship bracket and the bottom two
to the consolation bracket as is
traditional for
park champs so a really interesting
format alexander i particularly like the
touch that you do get a point if you
make it into the tie break even if you
lose it i think that's
you know that really acknowledges uh the
entry of a close match
yeah absolutely and i'm excited for this
close match to get started i'm just
waiting for nick and techtone um i know
that uh techtone was making our chat
laugh a little bit before the game he
seems to be a very colorful personality
from what i've seen
yeah we've heard uh he has some pretty
interesting reactions when uh when cool
stuff happens on the board so
uh i think it's in all of our best
interest to to see close games because
then we might see some colorful
reactions
yeah and on top of that just a reminder
so nick a30 this is going to be his
first game in pogchamps oh there we go
liftoff uh all right why don't we i see
his name as
nicholas uh i don't think chat does
now that i'm looking over no they they
probably do see that as well so you know
great usernames and he starts off with
e4
when did you start off with when you
started playing chess e4 d4 e4 i i
started as an e4 player i think the vast
majority of players kids adults start
off as one e4 players um these openings
are often easier to understand and i'm
slightly concerned alexandra that
is
techdone making a move does he plan to
make a move well e4 is a very you know
rare opening move to uh c so he's
probably just trying to figure it out
from here
yeah it's a complicated position uh
there's a lot of possibilities 20 to be
exact exactly exactly
you know i love how you just know that
well i hope that's right i yeah you know
i learned that that's one of those
things you learned ten years ago four
horse moves
that's why i didn't major in math
oh i guess uh i guess the pawns would be
twice that okay yeah that makes sense
that makes sense
um
oh we're listening in my bed
let's see what's going on this time i
don't this time i don't need it i don't
need it uh knock a cap i was expecting
someone looking a little bit uh a little
bit different
okay all right no this is fine this is
good this is good this is great
this is um this is really good
this is this is so good that's a great
ice cream yes that is a great sub
okay okay
okay
you look a little bit different yo night
knight's a c3 or you're a coward
not to say you whatever
congratulations no funnel out here
come on let's go
you're lucky dude you got me this time
okay
no i'm going to viscerally
annihilate you
give me one moment nicholas amy uni god
that me up
no idea who the that was
all right that's right you're doing good
oh canadian huh
all right
okay so this is obviously the um
the brazilian pumpernickel
i've researched this a lot
this is a very very like mid five to 600
elo
uh which is my exact counter
uh because once again
i am a complete idiot
but
as long as he doesn't expect the
bulbasaur's uppercut i think we might be
able to pull out a w
but we'll see right now he's biting his
time because right now he's thinking
well i don't know what the to think
is that a hippo
wait is he drawing a hippo with his
chest pieces who knows nicholas amy uni
who knows i think i've been deuced
i believe i've been duped
oh castle bro
excellent progress play
you know what they say
alexander i'm speaking you know you got
some on the ropes yeah
castle out of nowhere
letting him go there
so i know that he plays the hippo
against everything but nick is also
getting the dream position for any
beginner whenever you learn what to do
in the opening you're told to center
center centralize your pawns bring the
knights out
get the bishops out then castles so now
we'll see how far beyond the opening
nick a did his prep
well there's your answer bishop g5 and
yeah this is just what the doctor
ordered the perfect piece placement but
the great thing about your hippo i don't
think i need to i want to try to get
that let's that guy let's get his
perspective first really quickly
um
just a little bit quieter than
if i could somehow get my queen if i can
move my knight no i can't it's defending
let's just play it safe and that way we
back up our pieces right there
he's probably gonna move like that right
and then he could move there if i go
back so i almost want to if i'm yeah i
almost need to
um i almost need to go back here
in which case he does that and it's
defended again so i'd waste two moves i
almost feel like i should just call a
mistake on that and back up
um unless he's leaving something open
which i'm not really looking for
if i do this he does that i do that no
don't do that no
i gotta back up
good job good play here
yep
i like that he wasn't afraid to retreat
his bishop that's something that's
always pretty tricky it feels
counterintuitive but
he seems to be really sharp for having
you know committed to this a few days
ago
no absolutely you can see in his thought
process he's he's seeing uh key squares
he's easily identifying threats i was
just going to say that
the good thing about the hippo is that
you can play a bunch of moves fast
against anything and we've seen uh that
particularly new players in park champs
one of the ways that oftentimes stress
and their sort of nervousness manifests
itself is in time management alexander i
think that's a big issue for some of the
newer players
and when you play something like the
hippo or another system
uh you can get a pretty big time
advantage early on in the game and this
is what we're kind of seeing as techtone
continues to
uh play very confidently and he's made
all of the normal hippo moves here
yeah absolutely i mean he is at a little
bit of a risk if he's always playing the
same opening at some point somebody
might prepare against his hippo and you
know you might see another really scary
game like his one against fundy that
ended in 11 moves but it doesn't seem to
be the case here which is great what are
your thoughts on h4 here
well h4 is a great move if you have a
rook on h1 um the idea is just to push
that pawn down to h5 and and try to
destroy
the pawn structure surrounding black's
king the issue is that because you've
also castled kingside
this comes with a lot of risk pushing
pawns in front of your own king
is is often just a very risky thing to
do i don't think it's a bad move though
a good idea to follow up would be to
move the queen out to d2 that would
connect the rooks and it would hit that
pawn on h6
would actually force tekton's king out
uh oh what's he saying he's going to
start violently vomiting
out of some confusion
watch this
queen a7
rook c8
queen a8
and he's gonna have to move three times
and judging on his current peripherals
we got him in our sights okay he's
protected
all right i i don't know what the
you're doing here i'm gonna be real
i'm gonna be real nicholas i think
you're washed up i don't want to say it
but i'm i'm merely just saying what all
the people are thinking right now
okay
and i'm sorry exactly i didn't mean for
it to come out this way but
it's going to
on your next move
tell you what
if you're the true giggit chad that you
think you are nicholas
amy yubi yubi yubi
take your pawn
to b4 right now if you have any shred of
respect left for yourself
he's provoking him and he doesn't like
to push the pawns and the bread
i have a feeling nicholas will continue
to switch
yeah
g5 or h5
right so he is i mean we are seeing some
really interesting chess the prophet
once again predicts what's going to
happen on the chessboard of course you
want to be careful when you're pushing
your pawn so far away from your king
because if your attack doesn't pan out
then you're just going to end up with a
really weird king side here but now that
techtone's queen is on the other side of
the board do you think he can actually
break through on the king's side
well i was going to say he won't be able
to if tekton plays the right move which
he just did very very quickly h5 pushing
the pawn and completely locking up the
king's side that's another
counterproductive thing about pushing
out all of your pawns is if you fail
to orchestrate some trades the position
gets very very locked up now white's
king is really exposed in the long run
that's not an immediate problem because
as you said black's queen is nowhere to
be found however rook left rook to a3 so
the position remains approximately
balanced and techtone follows through
with his plan he wants that queen all
the way back in the corner
where it creates a battery with a bishop
and here you could tell
you know that nick is newer to the game
usually you don't want your rook in
front of your pawns you want your rook
behind being able to support them um i
think it's always super difficult when
you're in the middle game trying to come
up with some plan he already went for
the straightforward things like pushing
over his pawns and i think this is where
techtone's prior experience might make
him the favorite
and his
rapidly growing time advantage as well
and you're absolutely right because
black's pawn structure is so solid a lot
of these pawns are defended by other
pawns
and it's incredibly hard to make
progress
unless you have a really good
understanding of how to use your pawns
uh to create weaknesses but here comes
tech tone with f5
that's a really nice move
if nicolas takes that pawn with his e
pawn
then that knight on f3 is going to be
lost this is just going to be a moment
okay wait let's see what he's thinking
dang he's going to take my knight
um
unless i move up
who
don't think he sees that battery though
that queen
goes there and he has a lot of access i
feel like if i have to take this
oh he might take it and lose his knight
he hasn't seen it yet
i think he just did
waste some time
yep there it is
tech tones bishop about to swoop in and
grab that knight off the board
he takes for the pawn right
that's
gonna think with that one then i can't
move this forward
so i got to start preparing for that
um
though i missed it i was looking at the
live board which is why i reacted to
back there
he's further off the board i remember
so
should take with a rook here and he does
but now he's going to see the knight
under attack in that variation so he has
a chance to save okay
so now if i'm my queen's watching that
um oh no
if i can't move
he didn't see it but
okay i i think we're a little bit ahead
of ours so do i move my knight or i take
his rook i think i think his rook and
then i'm defending my bishop oh my god
oh but he's got a queen
queen
oh shoot
okay i see what you're doing
um i think what i have to do here is
move the queen
yes that would be a great plan
[Music]
get out of there don't take that either
i don't have to go as my queen actually
okay that's a good sign
good solid movement he removed it a lot
of time
yeah he's low on time his king is weak
this is still bad and look at the speed
of techtone's play he's playing on all
sides of the board now striking in the
center
oh this is looking bad for white
it is looking bad for white but at least
he was able to recover what i thought
was just going to be
a piece entirely um but yeah being down
five minutes is going to be way too much
for him here oh no
uh there goes the bishop i'm actually
checking you dude
oh wait you didn't take it you didn't
take my
why didn't you take my bishop was it not
good enough or
wait why didn't you take that
that's kind of mean i thought my oh
i thought my bishop looked pretty good
but i guess he didn't want it
all right
with the check can i get you with the
tommy pickles or no
[Music]
if i'm gonna be mind blown
i think i actually should have moved my
rook up
but i think i goop for that dude
but then again me moving that protects
the mouth that was just bad that's all
right it will be okay listen if he
doesn't if he doesn't oh i'm going to
take something here right
okay he's taking the bishop
i want
that correctly takes the rook
nice nice
bishop can do whatever the he wants
i want the rook
now the bishop's hanging
and he doesn't move i think this is the
play right
that is a really good move though he
brings the rook up to the second pretty
good about this
tech tone is playing really well oh that
puts me in shape that sucks
but don't worry he's going to freak him
out am i crazy oh god
all right you want to take the horse i
don't want that
oh my gosh
all right well i'm in check does it
oh guess i don't know what's going to
happen but if i just move over here
the rook can move in and win black's
queen
eight minutes bro what are you gonna do
i think he pulls it off i mean that
sucks oh my gosh
that does not suck
okay that's not good you should not be
laughing hold up
[Laughter]
hold up
all right just take my queen it i
don't even want her whatever you're up
by a point nicholas calm down
all right
you're not winning this
okay you're not the main character of
this timeline
but he still has a time advantage here
he does so if i had to predict one he's
still the favorite just because
five minutes is worth more than however
much he's down on the board here
i agree completely although nicholas is
riding the wave here he's playing
quickly and look at that queen on d6
it's hitting two of black's pawns if
that pawn on g6 falls the one next to
black's king
uh then the other pawn is gonna fall and
white's gonna have three pass pawns the
king should hide out on g3 here that
would be the easiest
way to escape the chess right because
he'd have his own pawn as a shield and
he'd be on a dark square so the light
squared bishop trying to never expect
this is good too
if i could do this is check but it's
also a free piece right there guys you
see that
if uh
if he does something with his bishop
here no no no don't you but i gotta
double check after he does it should
take that rook
um
that's a free
it's a
one step at a time
i love the comments about danielle being
more stressed
than the participants okay i absolutely
am
okay what did you just do white could
win black stroke now with a fork
dang he moved yeah okay but
one side to the left
queen f6 wins the rook
oh my god will he see it because he saw
the idea earlier so he might see it it's
also intuitive to check again but he
might be baited by the pawn yep it looks
like he
[Music]
oh my goodness
okay yes yes i can take his work now
let's go let's go
oh my god i think we got this i don't
know why this is so difficult
okay
now that queen can mow down the rest of
the pawn come on buddy
come on
uh you're gonna take that but i will
prefer to move it
i need to buy time i need to stop taking
so long with my moves though oh what
what
bro i swear i didn't mean to do that i
swear to god i didn't mean to do that
bro
oh
nick you had it
nick
oh nikki poo
oh my god nick
oh holy
you do hate to see it you really do
oh nikki chan senpai
oh man
are you gonna queen up
i don't think you should
all right i don't think you should nikki
chan
i don't hey man i don't think nick is
feeling too good right now bro
[Laughter]
now all i got to do is not this up
what happened with that's legit the only
thing
well stalemate's the only danger here
yeah i i feel like stalemate would be a
fair result at this point right
the thing is it's good that tecton is
actually leaving that pawn on the board
because it's a shield against from
stalemate and nick should just push it
and give it away
absolutely and the good thing is if he
puts his king to h6 he won't have any
legal moves he's gonna have to figure
out the best thing but he needs to go
king h6 here so that he takes away
you know any escape squares and has the
best chance for a stalemate if he's
learned what that is yet king of five
makes me feel like he hasn't
yeah i'll get pinned there
yeah
that is he's gonna go for another
i need to
oh that would have been so nice to try
it
shoot i should have went there so i
could have defended now i need to get by
this isn't going to work i need to
dang man
yeah uh i can't
and now i can't get back
he's trying to build the grand canyon
with a shovel shoot yeah i lost him
imagine i don't though
imagine oh come on to the side to the
side
if the a1 queen takes the pawn that
would have been oh no no it's still the
e3 i got to just stay away from the edge
of the board
i i got to stay near center and i got to
stay away from the corner
and i guess he's dodging the checks so
far yeah he is what they're like
oh
what is barbie little guy yeah yeah it's
a way to take the pawn too if the queen
takes the pawn that's stalemate i would
oh my god no i'm going to get out of the
i'm going to get out of the country if
that
imagine though imagine he can't what if
he can't close out i don't know
i can't believe i had that i literally
would have won you know i would have won
guys
i promise you man
this party
[Music]
no way
are you kidding me
like literally like holy
why is that even a thing you
call that a draw
i have two pieces on his ass
[Music]
are you kidding me that's a draw
well
yeah that definitely deserves an award
for for best games the high quality
chess that we
love and came here for right daniel
we absolutely came here for this and
this stuff only happens in pockjamps and
nowhere else and that's why we all watch
i mean you could not
have scripted this better in hollywood
that is insane
you know
so many queens giving away two queens
then there's two queens on the board and
then there's a stalemate
you guys we are gonna be right back
after a short break i cannot wait to see
what happens in game two if this is game
one see you guys soon
[Music]
so
that's a great size congratulations
here's a crazy thought okay
hi an absolutely insane crazy thought
if the king
has no legal moves
why doesn't he just lose
am i crazy for thinking that
like
if the dude
can't move
why doesn't he just why doesn't he lose
i don't i don't get that this is why i
can't checkmate you know what i mean
like
like he's dead
i had
four minutes extra on the clock
the king was so scared he himself
couldn't even move
that's a draw
that's a that's a draw
that's like saying that's like saying
floyd mayweather's a good boxer because
he hugs people
that's not even boxing
that's that's that's some telly
teletubbies looney tunes
all right well
i guess i guess i guess i'm really good
at race car driving because
i watched fast and furious one time
that that feels like a kick
in my heart
welcome back ladies and gentlemen
pogchamps is presented by coinbase earn
crypto by learning about crypto with
coinbase earn visit coinbase.com
chess and get five dollars in bitcoin
when you sign up
and verify your account
all right and um
i'm still wrapping my head around what
we just saw alexandra
that is that had more twists and turns
than the curviest road in the world that
was unbelievable and i think it draws a
pretty fair result all things considered
what do you think
absolutely i was thinking that during
the game i mean they both had so many
chances
it felt good to see them get a draw
because otherwise it would have changed
their psychology going into the second
game we know that they would have been
playing just for a win felt a little bit
bad this way we get to see another fresh
game where they both are fighting tooth
and
nail and i i think if you
uh do a statistical analysis of all the
results in pogchamps draws are pretty
much exceedingly rare in games with
newer players just because
the games tend to be you know are
decided by a pretty wide margin there's
a lot of extra pieces at the end so i
think stalemate is the most common
way to draw
uh for newer players who are not
as familiar with checking and making
sure that their opponent's king is no
squares but
i really liked techtone's confidence i
liked his time management maybe in a
couple of spots he played just a little
bit too quickly a little bit
too defending
all right let's listen in on what he has
to say here okay i gotta defend oh geez
this again oh my god
are they ready
um
yep well you were the one who said
section plays the hippo every game
yeah right
now
nicholas repeating the same setup which
is a good setup okay
absolutely
to square one eye
back to square one
literally
push these up so i don't want to move f
no always f which i can't right now
uh this is defending my knight so i
don't want to do that i don't need to
move that but i do want to claim some sp
okay so i can move um
this right now because it's defending um
and then what i'm gonna do is i am going
to
castle
and now i remember okay great move uh
anna said to move my
queen not for the reason that i think he
made it but i feel like i should claim
some space while i can
um
this is kind of scary because it would
leave my king kind of vulnerable but
against what right now i would just be
claiming some space and it's also
defended by the knight
which i'm liking pieces
that white has okay now i could move
yes this up okay i see why anna said
that too because like and i got
wait ting h2 is correct boom
he takes i take
if i can move
ah
but then he takes
don't sack the knight it's not worth it
don't do it what is there here there's
something here there's something here
man
there's not
there isn't anything super special i'm
gonna stop defending this which he could
do that no there's not okay so i'm gonna
stop defense i need to get him to move
that i need to get him to move that
i love how excited new players get about
checks okay right okay
it really is but he's no he's made the
same mistake again should i have moved
my no i couldn't have okay so he just
played that really well then
um
oh yeah this looks like a repeat of last
game but they flipped over the board uh
and once again he's making a similar
mistake where if you push your pawns too
far and your opponent blocks them then
you have no attack and you've managed to
weaken your kingside position here
but again it's just very difficult to
come up with a plan in the middle game
when you've been you know playing chess
for a few weeks or so
that's right and
also that knight on f6 which is now
undefended it landed him in a lot of
trouble tektone made this excellent move
pushing out his own f-bomb in order to
open up files uh so that you can attack
black's king
and i feel like that's gonna hurt him
again i think he's gonna push his f on
again i feel like when you're newer to
chess you repeat ideas that worked out
for you but
let's hear it from okay you know what
the man himself maybe you are operating
on levels that mere mortals don't
understand dancing around here
he's repeating the queen idea come on
bro
see now you have so many attack options
like you know
rook to
be a rook to c8
rook to ea rook to f8 bro dude if i take
those pieces because because he know the
problem is he's paying the next patch
because in next patch they're under
they're influencing another warp
and what nether warp is is that rooks
can actually go
backwards
and appear up here so he's playing
nether warp
but he doesn't realize that we're still
on patch 1.5
[Music]
go get there
over there
[Music]
hey he's creative absolutely giving him
points for that no this is
he's like in another universe
by the time we've rolled out of bed
you're moving you got this big man oh no
come on bro
oh you're right not today
in fact he locks up his own bishop he's
playing way too quickly alexander look
at his clock he's got 10 30.
he has to he has to take some time after
any pawn move is made
oh man you know donya he was thinking
about that new thing he explained where
the bishop transports to the other side
and then he could still take the knight
bingo bishops can jump over pontiac
they're they're going closest
yeah here comes rick a6
i like it they're consistent they are
consistent um
and at least for nick he's not going to
be opening up the position to those
monstrous diagonal bishops over there
that being said
this is just
strange play bringing the queen to b1 to
a2 and the rook is once again going in
front of his pawns but that's that's
what we came here to see
yeah that is and actually this idea of
getting the queen to a2 there is a name
for that in chess
now i'm not saying this is a good
application of that maneuver but there
is an old player over 100 years ago
named rubenstein
and rubenstein was one of the best
players in the world in the early 1900s
and he played a very famous game where
he actually did exactly what techtone
was doing now he was playing black and
he got his queen to a7 but the position
was wide open so the queen was just kind
of sniping at the position here it's
surrounded by his own pawn so it's not
as effective
yeah it's
you know maybe that's what techtone was
doing he was studying some rubenstein
and he just forgot the details of the
position yeah
great explanation there um and and here
the tricky thing is at some point the
position
in the position the players are going to
have to decide when to open it up i like
that he's playing rook ac1 it makes me
feel like he's going for c4
and at that point he might even be
undermining the center trying to put
some pressure on e4
and i like a4 that's kind of a
prophylactic measure
and i would imagine tekton's going to
push his pawn up to b4 he likes doing
that and then if nicholas plays b5 the
position becomes
completely and utterly locked up in fact
that's just pretty much a draw
although you just know that if that
happens the position's not going to stay
low they're going to find a way to open
up the center
do this close the entire position and
then just let the craziness
out on the board yeah some things
they're going to find a way to break
through the break through the lines
let's see what nicholas is thinking
about
so
pause champ
right
okay
i mean it's good that he's trying to
make it on his opponent's turn
right
i really okay now that i move this guy i
can move that and then i have my queen
in play as well and then there's three
um okay so he's gonna take this
okay so they're not closing the position
okay so he's looking to make something
happen right there after i take he wants
me to take that
um
we want you to take that
correction
i might just trade
otherwise
he likes bringing his knights out but
you got to be careful about where your
opponent's pawns are don't go night
before
yeah
very good point if i go here that's a
trade that's a good one i have this and
this he has that and that
so i need like to put my queen there
or not even there
his thought process has been
very concise even if he's missing
calculations he's clearly very sharp
with how he's approaching the position
um i wish he would see a takes b3 uh
before
but
even just playing with knight a5 at
least he's forming a longer term plan
instead of just pushing pawns
that's absolutely right i think he has
some of that the good habits down he
needs a little bit of instruction in you
know where pieces belong what what to
look out for in a position but in terms
of the
this the way that he's going about it
i think he's got a good amount of
potential queen d6
getting the queen more centralized
that's a great move too
yeah slowly improving the position of
his pieces i mean for his debut on pog
champs i am super impressed so far
without a doubt
yeah i would still lock up the position
with pod to b4 if i were tech tone
but he's probably
i i think he's thinking about something
else but we'll see well let's see
once
okay so if i take he takes he takes he
takes he takes he takes he takes he
takes he takes he takes i take he takes
i take he takes he's thinking about
something
it's a ladder it's a ladder all right he
said that and then things just worked
out but i don't really know
i don't really know how to do the second
part but i know how to do the first part
so hopefully hopefully that was
impressive
hopefully that was very impressive but
other than that uh
i have no idea what to do here
oh
i don't even know what he's thinking
about he just made up all the legal
moves
[Music]
he was just no way right like i've got
to be honest with you
how many pounds
he has that you know what are capable of
capturing stuff but it's not many
where did i mess up
[Music]
come on tell me that was good
before that would have been a great move
putting the rook on a semi-open file
he doesn't have a direct threat
please oh definitely any move that
that's calm
is a good move it forces black to think
again he's below five minutes is
nicholas
uh he managed to accelerate the pace of
his play last game but it could be a
concern here and i like that tech tone
is taking more time again he's played
before this time it attacks the brook
yeah so nick played rook a5 very quickly
i wonder if he was
stressed out about his time situation i
see him arrowing the bishop so maybe
he's trying to um very early on protect
the pawn on d5 seeing some kind of ghost
threat regardless i like that it's just
a small move it doesn't change the
position too much and maybe it'll give
him some chance to recover on time
absolutely and he seems
fairly confident i think he's gotten
into a groove
this is a very hard position to play for
anybody alexander there's a lot
there's a lot going on there's
almost all of the pieces are still on
the board
and
that adds a lot of background complexity
forces the players to watch out for more
things so we actually see tech down here
taking quite a long thing
but let's listen into nick
okay but my queen
says anything
there he is the arrows are coming out oh
yeah
really so
finally tech tone pushes nice
no he was clicking on his rook
layering
first order of business move that rook
away
[Music]
i think he's about to
he hasn't called out the threat yet
though
don't forget about it nick
yay
nice job
i can't do that he wins but at least
this is still blocking that
yeah you're not really gonna make
progress on that queen side
i could move this here
those positions are the hardest this is
defending players
okay so what's he trying here so if i
move
this there
and then move it up
oh he's gonna try to okay
dang
so i need to back it up
or i could put pressure on something
um
i don't know about that there's not much
to put pressure on
yep but it is natural for man he's
making me play defensively so um like
i'm almost wasting moves like clearly
that wasn't the play bringing my rook up
um so it makes me
yeah like you see he's getting he's
getting
okay i see what you're doing
careful
you do
is
if i let you take
then my queen could get in the play yeah
i'm gonna let you take because you're
not gonna take
oh my queen will
win uh-oh
i definitely don't want to be doing this
then
no
you can move as well this is a really
interesting
really really interesting
you like you oh
just i need you
you did nothing bro that's so cringe
he missed it
immediately and he gets home
to me
fort with the pawn
you will die today
oh man yes nicholas
you
uh oh
now he gives up a knight too
yup but that might confuse tekton we'll
see that's true what if tekton takes the
queen
that is a very tempting move but then
of course he would give up his own queen
but that's a possibility
he's getting his bearings
i liked the speech he gave
but now he's fully focused he's not even
talking
he's stewing in stony silence let's see
if he can
figure out that that fork's not going
anywhere gotta gotta take care of the
night first i don't like that at all
okay
you should like it it's another i messed
up i think this is the play did i mess
up
oh i wanted to tell me i did good not a
that's still okay
that's the play right that's good
at least at least uh i don't want to
trade my queen i need her
respectable
nick can you just say i did good and
just
i would like
[Music]
thank you yeah now he takes the rook
and then he can i will be taking him off
because the queen said thank you
yep now queen you're gonna have to back
up again
all right you know what
i say that's worth baby
i don't know i think that was worth i
think i did good cursers i think that
was a good play i think that was a good
play
i think we need to see that cursor shift
to the left a little bit more and say
aye
no no no no no
okay that was almost tragic
what's almost
tragic okay that was almost really bad
uh here what do i just do this
that's pretty good right nice good place
wow
you went around the world and then he's
like yeah let me just take the night
actually yeah he had us in the first
half you know but then he came back
before the move and then he got it
nicholas has good instincts the
recapturing he wants to play
aggressively that now white's knight on
d2 is hanging
again um and i'm not just saying that to
keep people on their on their toes but
we know the game isn't over even if
nicholas had no pieces left as we saw in
the last game the game is still not over
too far danya too far
still so soon um and tech jones plays
another great move he not only defends
the knight he attacks the queen and he
offers a trade which would simplify his
position quite a bit um and and for nick
it it would be hard to try to go and
retreat the queen somewhere because you
also have that pawn hanging on b7 but
there's still that pass pawn on a4 that
might give him chances and
as we've seen these games are very
unpredictable
yeah and
i i feel like he he's going to take
white's queen because
any retreating move is hard to play for
newer players because oh he plays queen
a3 so he doesn't retreat
of course that queen could get trapped
tecton could move his bishop one square
diagonally to b4
and nick would be forced to offer a
queen trade
or lose his queen but
maybe tekton will take that pawn on b7
right he has quite a few good moves here
um and i i see nick eyeing the rook on
c1 that would not be a good trade let's
see he's gonna move his no he can't move
there
um i might be able to
oh
okay
um well
oh i can't take that because
he's defending
so
unfortunate i think what we would do is
man he's got really good positioning
like i can't do anything
he's going to go for my for a check
he's defending well
definitely
protecting the pawn on c7 i really need
to start moving quicker
so
okay wait if i'm wearing this time
i need to somehow
no i can't
i need to threaten
like this so i can threaten that but
then also be right here
but then
he would just take and then he takes
like he's got really good positioning
man i
in my my night is kind of
in a really tough spot like he has
everything pinned down oh you know what
i need to do
i need to leave my king with this no i
feel like that's going to take way too
long
ah man
that's the right sound to make and this
is
so what would your advice
oh
my okay
for for nick to try and save this
position but this is going to give him
some chances right i'll start by taking
white's pieces yep
wow danya you're so smart great movie i
know i'm this is how i
this is why they pay me the big bucks
[Laughter]
oh okay so he takes with the knight um
trading a little bit more pieces than he
had to but regardless he takes the free
piece and that's a win and on top of
that the big
advantage for him is that after d takes
e4 he frees up his bishop on e6 which
before had no play and now he might have
some nice you know counter play on the
king side potentially if his queen
somehow gets into f3 you know true
but tecton he does have this discovery
if he pushes that d-pawn forward to d5
i'll be very impressed if he sees that
let's listen in win by checkmating
i'm okay with this
that exchange
i feel great about i feel fantastic
i would really like to get my bishop
away from this psychopath
[Music]
let's just
dude let's just
quit around
and can you just get your queen
off my board
take it take it so i can trade because i
can't handle this pressure
anymore you're stressing me out thank
you for leaving holy crap
dear god i was getting anxiety every
turn all right now i believe i can jet
boost this up right
now that my life isn't literally in
peril
thank you for the pawn
poggy woggy froggy doggy
[Music]
i'm feeling i'm feeling good
we have three full minutes ahead oh that
sucks
does it
root for bishop ain't worth
he doesn't see that discovery if he can
push the pawn out
yep
bishop is aligned with black
dude i would be so good at this game if
i wasn't a complete idiot
what if i move this pawn forward one
space oh my goodness
is he gonna do it does he know it's
check i'm gonna go for it it's a good
question
he can't do anything right i get his
bishop afraid
i think he sees that as check he might
just assume
oh
right that's the play right
because now he now he has to okay and
then i just go like this no
that's a good that's a good play no
no great play though white nick is
starting to collapse wait wait how was
that not a good play i feel like that
was a good play was that not a good
player like that was good guess what
alexander right black and was that
i feel like it was going
i mean then the rook
still made part two question mark
i can i can see a situation with the
king
being on g6
and only having h6
but that's so far in the future but two
minutes for tech tone
34 seconds for nick that is a big
problem
rookie one great move uh obviously when
you're up so many pieces you want to
trade and i love nick's instinct not to
trade pieces i know it sounds you know
silly when you're down a queen but
you know when you're new to chess you
want to pick out the stuff you do well
and one of the things nick has done
really well is he's shown this
aggressive instinct yeah
i feel like i feel like it could be a
stalemate
i feel like it could be a sound if you
that's what you should go for nick
here we go again are you ready chat
buckle in two minutes now 150 for tech
tone
don't sleep on his clock either
i see a lot of pepe laughs in it
and look at that alexander counter
interesting actually that he did that so
if he takes i take and i'm kind of in
there but
he's gonna not do that and i'm trying to
think what he's trying to do
okay great move
sure
there is a check made in one he's gonna
move there
is there if he plays king g6 yeah oh
this is limited
is he gonna see it i think he's gonna
move down
ah tt
i knew it yes
yes
let's go
never give up
let's go baby
let's go
oh my goodness alexander that
that was so much to take in and what a
finish so confident
he didn't give nick a chance uh once he
started taking all the pieces
yeah he gave him a chance in the first
game but then he came back and this game
was just absolutely incredible
it was and
you know it's always hard in such
matches to figure out what was the
moment of the match what was the play of
the game and
you can argue with me here alexander but
i'm gonna say
um
you know that first game was so
topsy-turvy it set the table for a close
second game
and um really the moment when
nick managed to turn it around and win
black's queen
uh that was one moment that jumps out at
me he came out of nowhere but then of
course wondering that queen a little bit
later that whole segment
to me that was such a fascinating moment
i don't know what you think was that the
most yeah
i'm trying to pull it up uh i'll pull it
up in just a second because i have the
second game here um
but i will never forget that when
there's that many queens being blundered
you know that it is going to be the
defining moment
and we only see that stuff in pogchamps
we see so many turnarounds
uh first you're convinced yeah one
side's got it nothing could
uh and i think that mouse lift queen b3
that was really really unfortunate
um he was so close he he even saw that
he could win black's rook which to me
was incredible that was a long-range
fork uh with black stroke all the way
down in the corner
he saw that within seconds so a lot of
positive stuff to pull out of this for
nick but tech tone i mean we love his
energy his confidence
uh and ultimately that was what
shown
that that was what shone through
but absolutely
i should say alexandra if people are in
agreement if you think that play
deserves to be eternalized
make sure to sign up on eternal.gg with
your twitch account and type eternal all
caps in chat to vote the play of the
games that receive the most votes will
be turned into digital collectibles and
dropped on september the 12th with all
proceeds going to ride
our charity dedicated to making mental
health accessible three lucky viewers
who voted will win a free pack and we
will announce the winners and now you
can pre-order the pogchamps four pack
containing epic moments from this
tournament including those voted by you
there's a limit of three thousand packs
three packs for users sign up now with
your twitch account and watch out for
more info on voting
to turn play of the game into eternal
packs that
you can win ladies and gentlemen so
lots of stuff here lots of moments will
be
uh made into eternal memories and what
an exciting match we just
we just saw alexandra absolutely when i
get the pack i really hope that i get
the first game this was my favorite
moment so far eternal moment of pog
champs that is incredible we'll be right
back ladies and gentlemen we will see
you soon with our next round pairing
which is going to be harry mack and
justin binks you can enjoy his rapping
in the meantime
propane who could do with me no names
hey yo i'm here to get loose check the
vibes i produce i storm on the industry
like i was zeus i'm back again i'm about
to cause a murder spree they heard of me
no exaggeration no hyperbole i'm here
for my people y'all know what we catch
oh they wanted to be emote only during
match okay for sure i just got the
notice um harry mack you know i'm bout
to help you keep focused yeah and every
time i flow i'm the hottest got the text
from my manager i'm saying cool i got it
how do i switch let me look real quick
and maybe my mods can assist with this
oh i see emotes only chat okay
so when the match comes i gotta switch
to that but uh but not yet so
there we go and the reason is um i can't
have people showing me
you know telling me what i should be
doing like yo the queen is available
grab the queen
um which i'm sure was happening last
time uh last time i just didn't look at
the chat at all um for the record
no but honestly i didn't look at the
chat because i'm here to actually learn
and and uh you know
the only way to learn is to take a
couple l's in my case lots of l's you
got to lose a lot when you're
you gotta lose a lot when you're
learning chess man let me tell you at
least for me i don't know
tell me your experience the chess
players out there especially ones who
were recently beginners
did you lose a lot in the beginning or
did you just start winning right out the
gate um while you ponder that question
by the way thank you for this level 2
hype train 68 percentage points my god
b-ball is life thank you for re-subbing
jackie nimble thank you for the sub or
was that a gift yes that was a sub thank
you so much and it's gone thank you for
resubbing with prime hype train is not
gone though it's still rocking
um
yeah shout out to the mod squad yeah
we're switching to emote only
for uh
for the actual match yes losing is good
you can learn from it let me have a
snack pack too while we all chill here
waiting for the match
level two complete let's go
chess weeb what up what up you don't
start winning that's a fact yes i have
learned that firsthand and uh makes
sense same thing with freestyling same
thing with uh really any um
endeavor
any new endeavor
level three complete let's go mission
and lubang what's going on
oh i just got the message we're about 10
minutes out
sorry for
chewing
to be clear
we are back
joined by nick a30 and techtone who just
ended up winning the match by one and a
half to zero and a half
nick i know you came in pretty recently
you've been training chess you already
had a great performance to start off
with where you were maybe the underdog
in terms of experience had you not
accidentally mouse slipped your queen in
the first game no
i don't even know how you recovered from
that and didn't give up did you learn
what stalemates were before going into
the game or was that your first one yeah
yeah so i was actually like i've been
doing a lot of research lately and one
of the things
one of the first lessons actually i was
on like chess.com is like stalemates and
i was learning how to check a king when
you have two rooks when you have one
rook and a king when you have like you
know all these different scenarios and
sad enough it didn't even get into play
but um i've been doing a lot of research
so uh i'm you know i'm happy with the
performance never back down never give
up
well we were definitely impressed and
tech tone big congratulations to you
uh so many things to talk about but in
the break uh you piqued my interest you
were talking about the tommy pickles uh
can you remind us what this maneuver is
how did you come to know it
um and it was just so cool so
put me through the blow by blow sure so
i'm pretty sure jt trained me as a joke
and i'm pretty sure he taught me
incorrect names so that way i can learn
him easier because he makes him fun so
he calls that move that tommy pickles
where you put the queen behind your
bishop that way it can jet boost across
uh the board and like a double threat
like you take with bishop they can't
take back because you have your queen
there and because like one of my biggest
biggest weaknesses for chess is that i'm
really dumb is that like if they make it
easy and fun to learn with goofy names
then i can remember it well and
hopefully that makes it for the lack of
iq
uh you don't have a lack of iq the way
you were playing that second game was
actually really impressive and what i
noticed is it was a very difficult game
because it was a super close position
but as soon as you open it up you came
in with the tactics um what would you
say you feel like your your strengths
are because they definitely shined in
that second game uh my strengths well
it's not checkmating because i stalemate
you did checkmate in the second game
though
yeah um that's true i was i was so happy
about that i'm not gonna lie i was i was
over the moon
uh my strengths i think i just um
i
for the first 80
of the game the pressure doesn't even
phase me but it's the la the first 80
percent
the last 20 i'm i'm i'm i'm a nervous
wreck but first 8 cool is a cucumber no
sweat you know i'm doing my thing i play
my game i try to make my opponents you
know
be forced to play my game because i do
the hippo i do the hippo every round i
will always do the hippo
and it's nice because it puts the
pressure on them and lets me just wait
and sit back and see when they mess up
and hopefully i'll be there to
capitalize so that's me and plus i think
my strength is just having a lot of fun
because chess to me is a blast like i
love it it's so it's so
it's not relaxing in this setting but
outside of insertable it's very
therapeutic it's very calming i love it
i i agree completely nick today was your
park jam's debut so i wanted to get your
take on that uh how how stressful is it
to make those first moves or do you feel
like it's just like any regular game you
play on chess.com how did you feel
throughout the match yeah it definitely
felt a lot different so it was a lot
more stressful and i feel like so i
recently just got into chess too because
i remember actually um i got tagged in
something that was actually from uh the
bow test twins and it was like i think
she was like taking off and it was doing
like she was doing some amazing work
with regards to like chess and so like
they used some clips to describe like
twitch and they had a montage and i
think i was like people were tagging me
there was like a fortnite clip in there
and so like i realized okay what's his
channel and i started watching um both
of them actually uh
yeah yeah and then i started to like
kind of get into it because i played it
as a kid just for fun you know like i
played with my brother and we weren't
pros or we didn't really have a good
grasp of it but i did enjoy it
so like recently i just got into it and
it was actually just like a week ago and
i've been playing it since and
given the fact that i don't have that
much experience i'm still happy with how
i played you know moving the pawns
towards the center claiming that
developing my pieces but it was hard
going up against uh tektone because i
just feel like i didn't have a move to
make because all the pieces were
scrunched together and i don't really
know all the the scenarios to be in
really
absolutely i mean his hippo is really
hard to break
and close positions are the most
difficult for beginners so you really
put into play everything that you
learned so far i think you're going to
be rapidly improving you know tech tone
is lucky he got you this early into pog
champs before you start beating up
everybody
you both played amazing thank you so
much for being here best of luck to both
of you in the future and we will see you
guys soon thank you appreciate it thank
you
all right well
before we take a quick break let me
remind everybody that chess.com is happy
to be supporting rise above the disorder
in their cause to remove the two
greatest barriers to mental health care
access and affordability rad was started
by a world craft guide leader in 2013
and it has helped tens of thousands of
people all over the world receive mental
health care free of charge go to
chess.comrad to make a donation and if
you do chess.com will be matching up to
a hundred thousand dollars of the
community's contributions so if you're
having fun with chess you want to
support mental health this is an
incredible cause we will shout you out
and thank you thank you so much for
everybody who has donated so far and we
will be back soon
i'm so excited my god i'm so excited i'm
a little bit nervous let's wrap some of
the nerves away again
wrapping the nerves away uh yeah yeah
come on hey yo we wrapping the nerves
away
yeah yeah yeah tragic pepperoni said
today you are winning you're about to
hold it down till the very last inning
wait is this baseball no this is chess
but either way the metaphor connects so
direct yeah we bout to move up on the
square spitting styles that the rare uh
making moves i gotta prepare got to
visualize the move and the effect it'll
have cause if i make a stupid mistake i
might get mad you might see me live in
front of thousands of people saying no
god damn if this game is evil i hope it
doesn't happen i'm just saying it could
hey yo i break it down smooth so it's
all understood yeah h mac win it anytime
he's in the battle rap stand up guy 7-3
rapping caddyshack mac call of benny
then you know i'll be the best i'd be
blessed man my win is what i'm here to
manifest so let's manifest it i can't be
tested a lot of skills man you notice
what i'm blessed with so heed the
message i'm coming through to make it
happen i'm not known for chess i'm known
for crazy rapping but today man you know
you got the god amp cause i'm here just
to compete again in pogchamps yeah you
might even miss it if you blink moving
fast when i'm playing against enemy minx
uh not my enemy in life to be clear
about my enemy and pog champs yo i'm
feeling fear i hope i have the skills
necessary to compete hope i don't make
an error that don't leave my ass beat
but we'll see what happens coming up
with new stuff shouts out to neatly live
saying you suck yo i appreciate this for
the inspo and thank you for sharing the
honest info if some people think i suck
well that motivates me to keep on
flowing great so that i can demonstrate
how to improve when i'm out here making
moves these are all the people who'll be
locked into the groove are you talking
about chess if so then i kind of agree
but when it comes to rhyming with ease
well i don't think i suck at all then
again i suck the air out to rap his
lungs every time i spit it son yeah hey
yo you know i suck the mic in through
the vacuum lung energy it's mac bringing
remedies yeah and y'all know i am not
the fake type save the game so i suck
the venom out the snake fight check how
we flip it you know i'm on that rapture
the fat me winning the game that be
the tactic yeah coming through properly
i do it easily hey yo y'all know i love
bumpy easy e e pmd and the classic
grooves h mac man i'm sending something
nasty through i don't mean you suck bro
that's the word sorry hmac man oh i get
you frizzy like bacardi it's all good
neatly i'm truly not tripping i'm known
for getting busy with the microphone
flipping any mic i'm ripping it's about
to get shut down hey yo y'all know i rap
from here to buck town
hey yo i'm here to rock the hot jam hey
yo they quoting my lyrics and saying god
damn that's iconic that be the homie
with the most the one you seen on happy
hour you know he's the host with me i
spit freeze for my people off the head
poems uh they feel me from here to
redstone i'm guessing that's the
location on the earth let me improvise
cause my vocation is the verse that's my
job dig it y'all know they will survive
less my name is harry potter i be
playing live chess hey yo i'm here to
make it happen i'm holding down the
court they saying chess isn't no sport
no it's a way your life i'm slaying mice
i know i'm getting busy now and i'ma
make your head spin around you got the
dizzy style yeah where is he now you
know i'ma slam these guys damn fly you
know i be training like a samurai i be
snapping i hit you with the queen's
gamut out of habit the microphone i slam
it i'm a savage how you feeling feeling
great y'all know i be killing fakes
every mack y'all know i'm about to get
the illest mate checking five moves you
know i will maneuver with bars that
smoother i'm here to sooth you heal your
pain you know i'm like magnus whenever i
be in the game i'm about to body bag
this to be honest yo i might get body
bagged quick no telling still in the
show like a felon you all know i'm
staying on my word route honestly i'm
just freestyling to get the nerves out
hey yo i'm here to win the battle
protecting my king he's hidden behind
the castle
yeah my queen be the strongest the one
who moves in the most direction
stretching the longest yeah so i gotta
protect the queen but also use it on the
offensive know what i mean it's a
balance for me that's the biggest
challenge i'm way too defensive y'all
know that i meant this trying to figure
out how to hop up on the offense started
three and a half weeks ago
hey what's up everybody dash here
i want to take a moment today alongside
rise above the disorder to talk about
mental health uh especially in this day
and age now more than ever it's
important for us to recognize a couple
of things
number one that it's okay to not be okay
and number two to know that you're not
alone uh
i like many people throughout my life
have struggled uh with mental health at
different times and for differing
reasons
and everybody's situation is going to be
unique without a doubt
but i think the one common thread that
we can all latch on to is that we have
all struggled at some point in time with
something mentally uh and so i wanted to
highlight today uh the importance of
normalizing talking about mental health
the importance of reaching out to each
other
to those
in our friend groups in our families
those close to us to check in with each
other
at the end of the day know that there
are resources out there rise above the
disorder is a phenomenal organization
that can help you with many of the
things that you might need if you're
going through a trying time but at the
very least turn to those you love and
those around you check in with them let
them know that you love them
and until next time
stay healthy stay safe and be good to
each other
welcome back ladies and gentlemen two
pog champs and we have our second
matchup today on deck we have freestyle
rapper harry mack against variety
streamer justin minx and if this match
alexandra is to be anything like the
first one people better keep their seat
belts fast and tight
absolutely and
both of these players are super
entertaining harry as you guys saw
incredible at freestyling minx one of
the funniest streamers on all of twitch
they're also super similar in terms of
their chess experience i will say minx
has been coached by an andrea while
harry mack has been co-coached by grand
master robert hess so they have two
different coaching styles i always like
roasting my sister a little bit but
it'll be fun to see how the two of them
do and i i think minx is preparing very
seriously right now let's let's take a
look
definitely the link wait is there
supposed to be a link
wait what
you're freaking me out i'm on chess live
don't freak me out are you
trolling me
you know what that sound is
oh it's storage
oh a stomach
get in there
there it is okay
what 45.
she looks a little shocked
yep
it is
there's some very heavy breathing i
think she's a little bit nervous
philadelphia defense might not be you
know the sharpest but it is very
uh
stable as long as she doesn't
have anything on my music f7 i don't
have my music
both sides bringing their pieces out
mm-hmm
good stuff i was a bit worried she might
break our other knight oh my god i
castle the wrong side
oh my god i thought this was my king
oh my god
oh knight g5 would be very nasty here
yep that's what i was afraid of
um harry will have to see the move
though
and uh harry pushed d3 instead so now
even if she if he plays knight g5 in the
future she'll already be castled uh so
that will be okay now for minx
yeah very good development a little bit
passive as you said but
nothing wrong with that and both sides
of the knife this is high level chess
being played right here knight g5 is the
kind of idea you have to learn it's hard
to just kind of see that
and mink should definitely castle here
beautiful
this actually looks like a very standard
opening from both players
um you know a few inaccuracies but given
the fact that they're in the 200 elo
rating range i think we have to be very
proud of how they've started off and to
your point h3 another great move
covering that important g4 square i
think minx might copy him with h6 that
would be
a pretty good bet
or a6 and you often see uh newer players
play
their corner pawns up i think
uh they often don't like playing too
much in the center and there's a6
copying on a different side but still
now she might have b5 ideas in the
future
and we might see a4 or a3
from harry
a4 a3 would be a very impressive move
because that would imply that he's
trying to create some space for his
bishop here um let's see what he's
saying um
it's a rare moment when harry
is not doesn't have sick beats yeah
[Music]
donya have you watched any of the bakami
thai videos on youtube
yeah i i got introduced to that pretty
recently pretty recently you say that
with a big smile
we really need to have just a
compilation of certain pog champ games
with with that song it is incredible no
i'm familiar with the song
yeah
okay so minx did play b5 great move on
her end
um harry does see that as bishop's under
attack which is great he only has one
move
that is going to save it so he'll
definitely see it and he drops it back
now mig should actually take that knight
on d5 which would expose an attack
against bishop on g5
but that's
a pretty committal move that can be hard
to spot
it doesn't win a piece because harry
could recapture with a pawn and attack
minx's knight on c6 if that happens
true um so let's see what minx is gonna
go for here and she pushes a5
great instinct on minx's part
wow and c4 a good move by harry which uh
secures the knight on d5 and creates a
uh escape square for the bishop on c2
and look at minx pushing that possibly
pushes the pawn
do not underestimate minx she may have
been freaking out a little bit at the
start of the game uh but now that she's
cool
it looks like she's in her element now
[Music]
jump doing
that
face
what are you seeing that i'm not seeing
chat
because i'll tell you right now
you're giving me a lot of
anxiety
you're up my gameplay because
you are doing this emote
sometimes all i think about is you
he waving freaking me out
it is funny
singing
and harry is
i think we're gonna need a duet maybe we
could try to prompt them through the
interview danya oh absolutely
maybe harry should give the whole
interview and rap style i mean i was
listening during the break the guy is
incredible
yeah some might call him the daniel
naradiski of freestyle
oh i'm honored
okay he moved his bishop away
taking on b5 would have been a little
bit more tricky but he saved his bishop
so that's super important and now he can
recapture
um and bring another pawn to help defend
his knight on d5
solid position
and still ming should take that knight
that night is just a you know right in
black's face
and rook v8
putting the rook on an open file and
neither side has done anything
too wrong both sides are playing
cautiously but good solid healthy moves
rook b1 seeing the threat against the
pawn now a4 is saying
but
in park champs pawns are not
you know game deciding
things you know you could lose couple
puns
you could
um and rook a8 so minx notices that the
pawn is under attack
and she moves her rook back sadly that
doesn't protect it since it's also
attacked by the queen on d1 but at least
she saw that the threat and reacted to
it which is a good sign
and one of the hardest things for newer
players is spotting
you know when a pawn is protected
understanding that it could be attacked
twice and protected once and you can
still capture it
that's a bit of a roadblock as you see
oh the rook protects the pawn but you
also got to see that the queen
uh is another attacker on that oh
harry max
a free
knight and look at the speed with which
she just she ate that tonight
immediately
oh my gosh good for her
and you can
oh
oh poor concerted is harry
it's okay harry it's just a piece it's
not good
wait a second gotta re-centralize here
push that a pawn get the knight out of
the picture
yep absolutely and a reminder because
they
are both playing for a point in this
match uh the rest of their group is very
difficult this is going to be the
closest match they both have so it is a
very impactful one uh minx does grab
that that pawn on a2 let's see if harry
sees that his rook is under attack maybe
he moves it over to a1 and then can at
least recapture a pawn yep yeah move the
rook to a1 force the knight back to b4
the knight will have safe passage out
the rule can't move anywhere to protect
that b4 square and he's about to do it
[Music]
and minx she needs to bring that knife
back to b4
nice and she does there's a lot of
people in chat and i see that in terms
of
chat polling uh harry was actually the
favorite here so the fact that minx is
up a piece is very impressive so far at
least from what the people were deciding
yeah she she really managed to mix it up
in the opening or shall i say mink set
up
there we go bring the puns back down
here yeah yeah that was really really
funny alexander that's why they hired me
as a commentator i know they just wanted
your puns um
right harry sees the pawn on a4 he
doesn't take it he pushes b3 which is a
little bit concerning because now mix
minks can push the pawn to a3 yeah you
know you're rubbing off on me
you know i'd rather your chest rubbed
off than your puns but you know what i
can get
well max playing pretty slowly he's
really not in a hairy here
oh my god
black should definitely push that a pawn
forward to a3 as you're indicating and
that's a past font on a3 that's pretty
serious business but i think minx
will probably take the pawn on b3 it
would be my guess let's see what minx is
saying
um
she has a lot to say here actually
haven't you so talkative in a while i
know i can't even keep up
my gosh will she ever stop talking
i know it's really obnoxious alexander i
can't even think
there's way too much shocking going on
right now yeah absolutely but hey
on a serious note she's still up at
night
uh she's doing super well here she
pushes d5 which is not the best move
watch post my plan there
the hilarious thing is you could take
that pawn with a knight
and actually that's not bad right now
good sir
i didn't have one
ooh now harry could push that pawn out
to d6
oh direct bishop on e7 it
technically still doesn't win material
but it causes a lot of practical
problems for black will he see it
that would be a huge win
trades instead you don't want to be
trading when you're down a piece but hey
at least that pawn on e5 is also hanging
so he's slowly collecting pawns to make
up for the lack of miners
take my queen
take it
take her
yeah provoke him she's sitting there
she's a sitting duck right now
minx is my teammate we're both on team
envy
and harry is just incredible so well i
didn't think it was good i'm coming down
what lie to you there
did not see that one coming
she sounds like an irish karen with that
voice
yeah it's a good one
maybe three lots going on here there's
just so much hanging it's making me
nervous i know something something's
going to come unhinged here
i don't know what it is or who's going
to emerge with more pieces but
stuff's about to go down
okay so
bishop on c6 defended by the knight she
just has to be careful to not move it
queen is still protected
yeah just wants to play rook v8
everything's protected keeping the
tension
and all i will say
minx has made huge progress from when
she initially started minx has actually
been putting in a lot of work um so
she's she's playing better than her
rating so far
oh without a doubt as an area they both
are you would not i mean they're playing
closer to
you know 800 to a thousand rated players
than 200.
every time we say that we do
commentators
oh absolutely that means a piece is
about to be blundered on that yeah i
feel like a pizza i think i heard minks
oh no um
yeah brooke
i feel like we might see a bow test yeah
like chances of you know it's like when
you drive into a forested area
uh you see the fire danger sign i think
we should put a botez gambit percentage
risk of a bow test gamut happening true
i mean hey let's just trade those queens
off and right forget about blundering
the queens i mean in the other game minx
was playing box box and minx
and box box took her queen checked her
and instead of recapturing she just
moved her king away
now she's improved and made a ton of
progress let's keep in mind that that
was her first pogchamps game in her
second pogchamps game she hasn't
blundered so far so the progression here
is a very good story arc well
don't mince it alexandra because
we know what's going to happen
oh i mean i would never sleep on harry
uh you know what somebody oh
incredible freestyler can calculate way
too quickly
bill the queens are making me nervous
the fact that they're
not getting traded
of course the queen trade is good for
black minx is up a piece so you want to
simplify
nope don't do that
chad is a big fan of your puns
oh
they always are
bishop a4 attacking the knight on c6
minks sees it and immediately defends
right away
she's up an entire minute but harry's
also been playing very quickly which is
you know true to character
all right let's see what he does now now
if i were harry i would move my queen
out
and prevent the possibility of a queen
trade
but
he might also take that knight
seems to have his eye on
his bishop that is true and it's not the
worst move um
you know even trades
always find moves under let's say a
thousand ratings okay
okay recapture now queen f3 would be a
good move hitting that rook
oh yeah hitting the rook putting more
pressure on the knight on f6
but that's that's kind of a tricky move
to say oh yeah
okay four dimensional good move similar
now mingx has to see that rook
and uh let's she does
let's see minx is arrowing it we see
this on her screen
she's still super focused here oh
excellent
beautiful she moves out of the pin and
defends her rook
this is high level chess just absolutely
i'm not just saying that these are moved
i would play queens to this position
not that that means anything but
yeah probably
who are you dania
[Laughter]
oh man
someone in chat said this game could
easily be 2200 level i'm muting this
chat
okay i don't know about that but
i should have read the latter part that
was mine
alexander but look at these moves
putting the rook in an open file
uh oh
chat let's get a copy pasta going just
every every time people are hating
this game could easily be 2200
right jay schlatt is now my lover he
beautiful less than three less than
three
hi
i love the sub sub notification there
right five minutes to four minutes it
feels like this game might end up being
determined in time pressure the cool
thing is it's an open position there's
not that many tactics to fall into
um
but i'm going to make a prediction
i'm going to interrupt you please i'm
going to say this is decided by a
voter's gambit oh gosh okay continue
that's that's the spam oh yes chat there
you go this game could easily be 2 200.
heck yeah some new people are going to
come in and be like wow are we missing a
couple of zeros on on on the program
participants
yeah you know what's a what's a zero two
twenty two hundred
both contain the word two hundred so
basically the same thing exactly what so
nine h5 start making fun of me i'm
stressed i didn't realize i was in the
middle of a house tour
and then chad was like chess oh no what
is your plan
you take this guy she sticks here
my queen takes you
you're both going to come down and
attack me
oh no
she's stressed but she's up a minute and
up a piece oh no she's gonna play knight
g3 seems to me
i might be
no no you're not
far from it
negative you are not yeah
don't do it
don't do it no no no don't do it do not
play rook d8 do not no
no
there we go good good good good
my prediction would come true in that
case but yeah that's true let's let's
not make it i would love to see a move
like h6 just making some space for her
king
um kicking the bishop out
but you know her cursor seems to be on
the opposite side of the board here
which is also okay
but that's also a bad sign when the
cursor goes from one piece to another
there's a higher probability of a
blunder it means the player is unsure
rook b6 is a pretty solid move
it doesn't accomplish much but it gets
the rook out of the queen's purview
solid chest
[Music]
i hope she doesn't move the rook she has
to spot that bishop yep
what are you doing here friend
and thank you everyone who's donated to
rad so far
if you eat that and i eat you oh
no
she didn't take the bishop no i didn't
do that you played bishop
andrei tells me to slow down but i saw
the timer
oh
no what is he doing
the exchange okay she takes with the
king
black is still okay here alex
but
that king is so
exposed now to a potential backrack man
on d8 in fact white could try to
distract black's queen and then play
rook d8 with checkmate but that's a
super high level idea yeah yeah
my issue with this position after that
blunder for minks is that she still has
all of her pawns here and there's just
so many checkmate opportunities
and i think it's difficult to coordinate
the knight in the bishop at this level
uh especially against two rooks but what
this is moment is she gonna take the
rook she needs to see the rook on e1
this could be her comeback moment
she's still she might take the bond
though
and you know what's crazy not with the
queen though right we're with the bishop
but if she takes to the bishop harry has
a sick move here queen swings to g4
and
oh that's queen after the queen then you
have that mate so that's what i was
talking about but if you move the queen
then the knight on h5 is lost that's
super hard to see though first minks has
to take the pawn for that to happen
yeah if if harry sees that i'm
i'm he's goaded
yeah absolutely um
but first
will minx see the rook on e1 or will she
grab the pawn on c5
we don't know chat this is the worst
thing to do
we just hope she doesn't take with the
queen that's right
attempting move because it's not a
retreating move i feel like
new players like i said okay she brings
it back to b8 solid
rank and we'll take it yeah she's she's
protecting herself here that was smart
see you did say you did say you did say
there would be a bonus gambit now we're
going to see some queen trades
well this does blunder a rook though so
it's a it's like a half one it's a half
of this game yeah
yeah
um still you know chat this this game
could easily be 2200
well mix is gonna be up two
pieces hairy panics here with a queen
trade that
also results in a rook
that is offered and mix takes it
will we see a knight in bishop mate
oh my god what i i i
you know what the worst still don't know
what the result is gonna be
damn it if harry pushes that pawn to c6
it wasn't all the way to the rookie one
okay i'll let him talk but that pawn
could promote
didn't you say a pawn can build oh what
a bummer okay hold on right
the roman empire can be built with a
single pawn yes these games all right so
what are we gonna do don't give it up
no
no harry push it
again harry also very new it's hard to
see when there's so many things hanging
he's doing a lot of logical moves and
he's been playing
i mean his lesson about how to learn how
the pieces move with robert was pretty
recent and he's playing this well mm-hmm
no absolutely hats off
i mean and harry's literally wearing a
hat so yeah
three by minx
that's a cool looking one but it blends
with this oh she played rook g3
if she i mean if she saw the pin that
would still i would still be pretty
hyped for it even if she's dropping a
piece some style points
it's going to confuse harry who's gonna
spend some time figuring out why you
can't take that knight
that's true
you might think it's a glitch
no sir
no sir don't eat me oh he sees it
mingx could make a drop
with a knight check on f1
let's see where she decides to bring her
knight after the king moves yep i i hope
she moves her night that would be a
great start
yes
hey
how's the time situation
two minutes fourteen now what for minx
now what
it's gonna get stressful here uh-oh
all right you guys the clock is on
you might make that draw if she gives a
check on f1 and she keeps stepping away
with her knight
there is no checkmate here
you can't reef organize your knight in
rook to give me oh my god
angula is now my lover i thought she
burped for a second but it was a sub
notification right
like a stress burp or something
harry's burning way too much clock here
deciding where to put his king there we
go
she's going for it oh my god we are we
might see no that isn't you're up at
night don't do it
i think characters
that's
so crazy
that's a draw
it's gonna be a three time unbelievable
in a draw is our result
we've seen two draws in game ones that
might be the first time in podcast
history we've seen that
okay with that
and and mate seems fine with it i think
minx was so nervous that just getting a
draw you know is enough to to encourage
her a little bit more and i understand
that when you have so many people
watching you play this new game it is
incredibly high pressure and just
getting something that isn't an l might
feel good even if she was up a night
here
without a doubt before we go on a quick
break i just want to add that when
you're new
you also don't have the greatest sense
of peace value uh you might say well how
can mix make a draw the night up but
it's hard to say you know what does it
mean to be a night up is that really
that good so that takes experience and
practice overall really impressive here
by both players and everything is going
to be decided in the next game it's
going to be a close one
and we'll be right back
i'm going to switch off emote only
quickly just just to talk to y'all man
to wrap with y'all thanks for watching
me
thank you for supporting me so close
god damn
your freestyle is a bit better
lesson learned yeah well hopefully i
gotta fully internalize the lesson
wow
wow should have ran let me see this
should have ran that bishop down to
check he moves the king then run his
pawns okay for sure for sure
great game hey what up rosen
great game super intense at the end
there yeah that that was crazy that was
crazy
um
wow
oh i'm on chess's stream all right let's
go every time we're on chess's stream we
freestyle
freestyle to get the nerves off to get
the nerves off what's up y'all chess.com
come on uh you know i dropped them bombs
gotta freestyle here on chess.com
underground like a m a straight up from
the sewer rap in front of thousands of
viewers hmac if you want the bars we
about to do this legendary artist in the
game like q-tip h mac i'm the freshest
on the scene gotta stay protected oh no
my queen ah they're coming for me what's
about to take can't make no dumb
mistakes and every time i get the
spitting man you know i need no cushion
they can't show me all these rappers
i'ma push them kinda like i'm pushing my
pawns i becoming this strong harry mack
you know we about to get this on i spit
this on another level i'm rapping just
as fast as i think i'm going against mix
we never met in real life but i'm hoping
i can cut down the king just like a
steel knife hmac i'm coming through
properly y'all know that they rooting
for me cause i'm known for deliverable
computing yeah and i'm saying on my
mission kind of boring and being drawn
by repetition yeah right to the mic i'm
a b-line guess we was in the same
position three times in a row automatic
draw h mac i'll be spitting through the
static bra i'll be coming off the top of
this in the brickley boss and when they
be coming to freestyle they'd be saying
i'm awesome yeah people love the way the
mackin is rhyming and i'm getting the
message in coming from simon i can tell
that they typing right here in discord
every mac i'ma hold it down like the big
lord leaving kids floored when i'm
spitting them fly every time i kick
these lyrics i'll be getting you high
yeah and when it comes to quality i'll
be lostless learning about chess that's
how they make the sausage hmac man you
know i got the power looking over all
your rappers from the watchtower saying
it locked and dude is often till i drop
into my coffin hear the scotland
representing and y'all know i'm infinite
they said you are on ads for one more
minute man y'all know that my flow's
universal i got everybody straight
watching the commercial if i keep
spitting these flames i gotta pay
attention or else i might be missing my
game h mac yo i got the styles i'm
kicking uh i'm complex like amalgamisms
move at the right angle like a knight go
diagonal just like a bishop i put up a
fight most important piece kind of like
the king but ironically quite weak yo
for my people i might speak can move in
all directions but only one square so at
the end they're like you're done there
only two places you can go now legally
that's what caused the draw all the
people see this here is the post game
commentary ain't another rapper in the
game half as warm as harry and when they
becoming deliveries i'm letting my
people feel this yeah when i go to chess
i'm saying fearless uh peace to those
supporting me i'm about to build a new
style this is forgery um kinda like i'm
working in them factories that poor
steel all of my lyrics is hiding more
real smooth like butter the track gets
smothered underground flows coming
straight out the gutter we really about
to go and get this thing on playing
chess like rizza so i'm singing bing
bong hmac and the sessions fitting raw
yeah i don't care if it's win lose or
draw the most important part of me
playing chess in this competition is
learning lessons so let me get a bit
better at the game while i'm coming
through lyrical i'm clever with the
flames i'll provoke you lyrically i
stoke you and poke you keep a straight
face kinda like i'm playing poker but
this a different game rappers getting
mad at me and in the battle league it's
like playing chat strategy is what
you're gonna have to need if you wanna
try to move past me g y'all know i'm
reacting hella savagely doing me up on
chess.com every time i'm spitting i'mma
bless this song yeah and y'all know i
really be a master i'm looking for the
checks then i'm looking for the captures
looking for the attacks and i go in that
order i'll be rapping live for the
chess.com supporters hmac y'all know i'm
a ninja of free kid dem so said you
still a winner to me yeah peace to the
fans who be watching the man up on
chess.com trying to lyrically slam let
me catch up with the chat yo y'all know
i'm the sickest when it comes to bars
off top i'm straight liquid i ain't
never selling out cause i'm forever
harry chess.com competition this is
legendary yeah y'all know i even get god
amped can't believe that i'm really
hearing paul champs ah i'm learning how
to play chess let me give major props
out to robert hess yeah that be the
freaking coach with the most every man
rap the mic to slay you and bragging
boats let's go
oh my god
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much more
learn more at coinbase.com
chess
wow well i think i was almost more
entertained by his rapping than the
chest every time harry is on he just
puts on a show but i'm definitely ready
to see the second game so that we can
get a decisive result what about you
danya
no absolutely i can't wait this has been
everything i possibly
could have asked for and then some that
was some unbelievable rapping we've seen
some really high quality chess
and i i always want to remind people
that you know when you've learned chess
six or seven days ago to play like this
is
is really really impressive and you know
we're not just saying that to make the
players feel good
uh what these players you know the kind
of time investment that they make
they're really really trying you can
kind of see that effort
um at every stage so
um i'm you know i always have a lot of
fun watching the games for that reason
yeah absolutely um and
we have the second game taking off just
to minx with the white pieces versus
harry mack again
they are the closest in rating in their
group this is going to be potentially
the decisive game
the game period i mean
oh they're talking to everything
that's not fair
that's not fair you're freaking me out
dude
i can't even show my screen that's not
fair i was rapping that's not fair
that's actually hacks
i can't thank
you like meg settles in
as the kim goes on
yeah she definitely doesn't
[Music]
look ahead and you're nice and nice from
your nice warm pad
you just remember what you're on my ass
yeah yeah you got a friend in me
wanna see you got a friend in me musical
games
[Music]
[Applause]
gonna give harry a run for his money
[Music]
something very similar to her first game
actually it looks a little bit like a
philidor
um but obviously opposite pawn on d4 and
the pawn on e3 but a system that she's
gonna be somewhat familiar with and i
know andrea coached her because it looks
like this was supposed to be a london
except that the bishop is on the inside
of the pawn chain alexander aren't you
aware of what the with the cool kids
playing out they're leaving the bishop
on c1 andrea's missed the train you know
she she keeps developing her bishop on
f4
honestly
that's not cool anymore on c1 well you
know who needs bishops to be developed
anyway you you should know that these
are basic chess principles out there
yeah basic chess you're making a fool of
yourself
stop
b4 okay
starting the queen side pawn attack i
feel like tektone would have a name for
this kind of move
yeah he definitely would well it was his
pickle technique what was it
i'm
terribly ashamed to say i've forgotten
it was so memorable that i've forgotten
that now who's making a fool of
themselves danya
you forgot karma wasn't on my side
knight e4 okay harry is playing really
well centralizing that knight and he can
support it if he wants with that f pawn
which are forward two squares if if
necessary
i think mix is going to keep pushing her
pawns here
well hopefully she develops at some
point too but she has to be careful
because her knight is protecting c3 and
if she does move it away just
remembering the basics of developing her
knight then she might end up losing upon
here
on top of that her position is actually
very cramped and quite difficult to play
and you
spoke and it came true once again donya
she pushed her pawns make prophetic
noises
yeah what's the prophetic noise tommy
pickles i think tommy pickles there you
go
so b5 attacking the knight
um where to put it and i can come back
to e7 or even to a5 as long as he moves
it
we'll be happy and minx is really uh
cat jamming here
yeah she's she's having a good time
uh she's drinking water that's that's a
change
i can tell she's taking it seriously
no absolutely
she seems a lot less stressed in the
first game which i think is going to
positively impact her play
or maybe not i don't know which is good
because the first time i think she took
the draw out of stress yes so the fact
that she's enjoying herself might
actually end up helping her as long as
she focuses in the right moments
completely agree as we see her
fianchettoing that bishop on b2
euro beat disney interesting
no
oh has he played yet
that's probably going to be a trade
no no no no no no no no i think she
realized it immediately
worried
[Music]
now this is interesting
she could take the knight first
but then harry could move the bishop
into b2 and trap that rook in the corner
so
either because she seems very happy so
she's not stressed at all about the
situation but i'm gonna arrow what you
just said so bishop takes c4 great move
because you're eliminating the defender
but then there was bishop b2 but he
would have had to see that
so she takes the knight or she takes the
bishop
and
he's
probably going to recapture
and now it's roles reversed harry is the
one up a night and
as we saw in the first game anything can
still happen
so
the tricky thing too is that he has a
safe square to retreat his knight
otherwise maybe she could have some nice
trapping ideas here
pawn on c3 also hanging and now the
knight on h4 is also high oh no now now
the wheels are starting to come off i i
just spent
20 seconds coming up with a word that
rhymes with knight and it occurred to me
that in that time harry could compose
and deliver 50 lines of immaculate
lyrics
hey i mean
he probably feels the same with it takes
him you know a long time to find one
move in the meantime you would have
found like a billion variations
well he's acquitting himself amazingly
here she's gonna take that pawn on c3
first which is even better than taking
the knife
i'm feeling something bad coming here
oh god we're so prophetic
we are alexander we're on on the ball
here we know what we've been playing
before
yeah shot is like a melody in my head
that i can't keep going got me singing
like
every day and my heart's all done we're
playing with play
does she realize she's in check i don't
think so okay
[Music]
pretty close
she's still
bobbing to the music so i don't know
yeah
hey
if i had her enthusiasm when i lost
games i probably wouldn't get as tilted
as i always do and it would have saved
me so much stress and elo over the years
so i i will give her kudos for that but
harry
sees the night on agents right now
he's on a roll and now he needs to move
the queen away it's being attacked by
pawn but he's super he's got seven
minutes he's confident he can put that
queen on e4 with check
or he could slide it into h3
yeah
i like both of those options
um and then he's just gonna figure i
have to figure out how to open the
position here
because even though he's up material to
win he will have to you know finish it
off and once you're new to the game it's
it's hard to figure out even if you are
up material because you don't have a lot
of experience winning and you know from
all my sessions with charlie one thing i
realized is that and i know people are
going to laugh at this but trust me
um for new players actually having a ton
of pieces can be even more stressful
because you know that you should be able
to win easily
but you know you're not as experienced
you're not as good at handling your
pieces you're not as speaking of
handling pieces uh knight b1 offering a
free night with played
instead of knight c4 oh
oh we don't
we are we going to see a three-time
repetition
make sure right
well barry
moved that knight
he did
and he moves it to d2 the the escape
artist
right
that night is getting out of there i i
hope she protects her rook here
that would be great
94 and then cue the james bond music
though yeah exactly
[Music]
bond
knight e4
yeah 94 would be such a nice move
attacking f2 but hey he moved his knight
away from the threat that's also
important
he's looking towards h2 maybe if he
wiggles his queen in towards h6 then
we'll see some nice checkmate tactics oh
nice move king g2 that's a great move
now
queen f6 would be the best but i think
harry's going to move the knight back to
g5
because
you know defending pieces with other
pieces is is a little bit harder your
instinct to just move them away
right but the reason you like queen f6
is then if his knight moves away his
queen can jump into the square and have
some really nasty checkmate threats here
nasty is right
i think he's looking for
squares yeah i see harry hovering over
his queen trying to decide where to put
it yep
here he is
oh my goodness i think he's about
sleeping up six wow
amazing man the myth the legend
beautiful move
keeping that knight entrenched on f3
and ming should take the pawn on c7
but yeah she might as well grab whatever
material she can
okay um
so if you were minx right now what do
you think your best chance to save the
game would be you're putting me in a
difficult time i know but i know it's
nice
no i would take on c7 and you got you
just gotta parry the immediate threats
and hope for blunders and and
you know that's what it starts with you
know you blunder a knight and then you
blunder a bishop and before you know
you're only up a queen or only upper
rook so
if i'm minx i'm taking on c7 i'm trying
to play fast
and and praise obviously fair enough we
also have grand master robert hess harry
max coach in the chat saying let's go
he's here to support his student that is
so wholesome we hope you're doing well
no robert
of that hess
yeah it's true you hope he's doing well
come on alexander
uh what was i supposed to say
why are you not here with us
robert we we miss you what's going on
we really do robert was replaced by some
fully incompetent commentator i can
barely even watch fog champs now
i know it's just so weird that one girl
who just doesn't stop talking with the
red shirt i was talking about that one
uh
fake gm who's basically an impostory
keeps rejecting a grand master to earn
fans but embarrassing truly i know or
did really the lowest of the honest
thing if you do that
i feel like chess players are actually
very self-deprecating because they just
they're so hard on themselves whenever
they make a mistake
um we need to learn from the content
creators like minks who's just been
positive and jumping out regardless if
pieces are dropped
that's my favorite phrase is don't be so
hard on yourself i totally listen when
people say that
yeah you uh
dania smash you're right
well harry played e5 he's opening up his
bishop maybe looking towards h3 he also
had a free pawn on h2 but i like the
idea of trying to bring in as many
pieces as possible towards the attack
especially you know 200 rating range it
is difficult to check mate with less
pieces so you know what just bring all
the pieces to the party if you got them
uh no definitely
very focused on her on her music i'm
choosing the right same thing when i'm
tilted i always try to find the right
song thinking it'll change the player
but really it's just me
is that a remix of careless whisper
it sounds like it
it's a little bit too upbeat for the
position
i think the regular version would be
would be more suited for this position
i think she's mad at chat though in the
first round
yeah my king though you got my king i
know she was a great observation
though i feel like she's only getting
that 10 moves after she lost her queen
i thought
it is
[Music]
the way
i like this trick
[Music]
i am sensing both of them take the queen
take the queen
no don't move the king king takes f3
leads to maiden one
she doesn't see that it's hanging
oh my god oh my god is she gonna move
oh my god
oh he's got to be breathing a sigh of
relief
i'm telling you it's stressful to have
so many extra pieces
you know people joke about me wanting to
publish on the botas gambit but it is
just so relevant for new players you
know
it really is no it's it's the most used
most useful chest phrase
oh my god
wow
okay well she's wow
broke back to d3 she wants a repetition
i mean i i mean
she doesn't have a lot of options here
and there
there comes the rook she's gonna have to
cover with rookie three again
yep
i mean he's
has enough time okay he's trading off
that might be an easier plan for him too
trying to figure out where the mate is
is very tricky
and it's easy to lose on time that way
you you can burn new players can burn
three four minutes yup in a heartbeat
just looking for that mate that he loses
yeah
geometry she takes it the king okay so
rookie 8 would be
a good idea here
and
this is good advice from you know ludwig
and he always says when he's up he often
just tries to liquidate now it's a
little bit easier
there there it is
and then once the king goes to d3 you
can take that pawn on d4 with the queen
yeah let's see if he's gonna see it he's
hovering over the knight which would
still be good because he's taking pieces
not as strong as taking with the queen
but still great
it's hard to make a bad move in this
position to be fair
queen c6 is also very good to cut the
king off
all right we are back to our live board
here you guys five minutes versus 3
28 and i know a lot of you are thinking
this is a 2200 game
uh what's your result going to be
still come back chances here we have
seen everything and we really have
unless queen c2 is played if queen c2 is
played then we know harry knows what
he's doing yeah if he hits queen c2 uh
then we just need claps all around in
chat because he not only has been here
entertaining people but seeing the right
moves rook c4 also solid he's attacking
the pawn on d4 it seems like he knows
the simplification strategy
one and only one thing worries me it's
not even stalemate possibility it's
black's back rank
um i don't know how i could get a rook
there because rookie one could be
captured by the knight but if i'm minx i
wouldn't even try rookie one
because if harry doesn't see it
you know that's all that's all it takes
come on minks try to cheese him
minx is a fantastic troll she could go
for something like rookie one oh yeah
she just has to give it a shot
see if you were playing it over the
board game you'd play rookie one and
then look look to the side and try to
distract your opponent yeah your
opponent's visual fields but play rookie
one gift your opponent ten subs
uh right and hope for the best or a
hundred or yeah whatever it takes okay
he sees queen c2 blazes beautiful
beautiful dashing white's remaining
hopes how has he been playing for only a
few weeks
crazy
[Music]
they got me in a corner
that made me think she doesn't like the
position
rook c3 excellent move
yep rook takes a3 is going to be
checkmate
she might as well rookie one for the
lulz
you're right maybe he mouse slips with
rook b3
i think the instinct is to bring it
closer to your king though so she might
go with v1
[Music]
okay
g4 if only she had one a few less pawns
she'd have some stalemate chances right
and now rook takes pawn as checkmate in
one
it's okay chat we'll still get a duet
between the two of them rugby three so
if she had played rookie one
oh
[Music]
still rookie won let's go
no
that's a few squares over too many uh
okay now harry has to try very hard not
to give mate on this move
queen b2 or rook a3 is both made
all he has to do is give a check
it honestly looks like she should be the
one checkmating with their reaction like
she's just not concerned
and she's the one celebrating the
victory we just need to keep our cameras
and it'll make sense
right but he's overthinking it i still
don't see a move on the board i get
knocked out
oh but then all right i see
and
no oh my god oh my god
anything can happen
dude i hate this part
he should be surprised no now that
no
that wasn't the right way to do it uh-oh
what
now the wheels are coming off alexander
he's only got a minute and a half if he
loses this game
i
will really
oh all right he's got to get it together
maintain composure start playing
composure new plant
oh my gosh that is so nerve-wracking
so that's why she was vibing she knew
that would happen
yeah no she we have two profits on the
stream today right okay
and she still has that back rank trick
somehow and now rook b3 potentially also
is annoying
um
but honestly i think if she saves it in
any way it's just going to be on on the
clock
oh yeah i know he's down to a minute
he's sweating right now oh robert robert
sorry robert it's worse for the coaches
to watch this it's not the players who
are the most stressed it's the parents
the coach is losing
their mind robert just punched a
computer oh my god oh my god i can't
watch this i can't watch this i can't
watch this i can't watch
[Music]
oh
oh it's terrible
oh no
oh my god wow
you know what i needed to do is lift
this guy up
ah
what a disaster
how
uh there's nothing to say in this
situation
oh my
god alexandra you know what's going to
be very hard is choosing the eternal
play of the game is going to be very
very hard
what might it be
yeah i i don't know what what would the
play of the game presented by
eternal.ggb
oh my goodness well this was an insane
moment this is the iconic moment of
pogchamps everything is possible that
should be the catchphrase and that's not
a cliche it's not an exaggeration this
is the one time that you say that and
you mean it rookie one
creating the threat of checkmate that's
the only source of danger for black
harry could have taken that rook he
could have given checkmated two with
queen b3 check but instead too focused
on the attack we know how hard it is to
make that final move alexandra knight c2
and minx immediately swooping in that's
called background checkmate all of
black's pawns are preventing the king
from escaping and that is definitely the
eternal play of the game and if you
agree with us if you think this play
deserves to be eternalized remember to
sign up on eternal.gg with your twitch
account and type eternal in all caps in
chat to vote the play of the game that
receives the most votes will be turned
into digital collectibles and dropped on
september the 12th with all proceeds
going to red the charity dedicated to
making mental health accessible and
three lucky viewers who voted will win a
free pack and we will be announcing the
winners
and uh the future of fandom is here
eternal.gg
that's where you can collect and trade
the best twitch and gaming highlights
from your
your favorite creators the same way you
collect and trade pokemon cards ten
percent of all sales goes to supporting
the original creators and all proceeds
as we said from park jam sport will go
towards supporting red a charity
dedicated to making
mental health accessible
what a moment you don't want to forget
it you're going to want to look back on
this and show your grandkids i was there
i saw it i saw mink's checkmate on he
ate crazy stuff alexandra honestly i'm
i'm still speechless daniel
i
i needed a moment i wasn't i wasn't
ready for that i cannot believe it
that happened
you know after the first match i thought
okay it can't get any crazier than this
then we saw
minks give that background check made in
a hopelessly lost position
while she was jamming out the entire
time as if she knew it was coming we
will be right back with both players for
a quick interview don't go anywhere see
everybody soon
uh i also see that i'm about to get
checkmated so it's definitely one of
those puzzles it's a situation where you
have to do something big here and i
think the first big move is
the second big move is
okay i don't know why that was the
correct answer
and then lift the pawn
okay uh i actually have no idea why
that was correct
hang on
uh
so that one yes that's obvious
it's like the easiest check gonna get
your bishop in position
and then i don't know why you go here
uh
okay so if we go here you can tr you can
trade
you can trade off material
oh but you're like still kind of screwed
here
i see okay see it's like you have to do
something better than that
uh i guess this is just like you count
all the squares and you eventually find
out that this one leads to the best
scenarios
okay let's move on all right all right
i have two rocks
if i push what happens
uh he cannot take with this rook
because i i've got the pin he'll take
with this
rook i'm pretty sure it's do this
[Music]
there's no way it's trade oh
i understand
it's trade and then this which forced
the app yep yep yep yep i see it
oh hello annie pog ebert that's me baby
all right i see a queen i see my
opponent has two rooks and i have an
unprotected king flush
so i need to do something huge here
there's no checks
free pawn
uh
here's a check actually
100 we check first
okay imagine this is this is pog champs
this is pogchamps
we are back we are joined by harry mack
and justin minx who put on a spectacular
performance harry i know you were
winning that second game and i'm sorry
and you must be feeling a little bit
down right now but minx you kept the
energy up the entire time you didn't
give up and you found that last
checkmate
how did you feel when you got it were
you expecting to win at all no pure
shock he was freaking me out every move
i did he'd do something and like my i
would scream every time i'd be like ah
didn't see that and my chat was doing
the this emote the whole time and i'm
when they do that i know i'm doing bad
or the paper so no that was a shocker to
me too
and harriet i'm so sorry that didn't go
your way but we were impressed with your
play it was it one of those things you
realized it immediately when you moved
yeah yeah you know what it is one of
those things because i've only been
playing chess for like three and a half
weeks now and so as a beginner i so
rarely get to that point
at the end where i'm like wow i think i
have opportunities to win this but i
just can't see them but i just couldn't
figure it out at the end i got
distracted i was so focused on lining it
up for me to win that i didn't see that
obvious uh uh gap in my planning there
no that's totally normal he was killing
me in the first half that was the whole
stress i made it even against box box
like you just it was like the turn
around from the last game because
apparently i had the upper hand which i
didn't realize until afterwards i was
told i had the upper hand um but no yeah
you were up a piece of my head actually
you played the first game incredibly
minx and then harry played the second
game incredibly and dania and i were
talking about how when you're new to
chess sometimes when you're winning with
so many pieces it's actually
overwhelming because you start spending
a lot of time of how is the most
accurate way to win and you did end up
getting you know to about a minute on
the clock when you ended up being the
mistake do you think the clock had a
factor in the result of the second game
definitely i think the clock is probably
like my biggest uh biggest challenge
because like you know left to my own
devices i'll just sit and consider as
many possibilities as i can but
obviously you know i don't have the
luxury to do that with with the clock
there so yeah
so that that makes sense and mink's a
question for you you obviously we could
see you go through the the full gamut of
emotions but i was impressed you were
continuing to vibe with the music you
were keeping your composure uh and
that's the only way to see an idea like
that do you feel like uh the music sort
of helps you
stabilize helps you get in the zone how
were you how were you so composed even
when things looked really grim in the
second game
when you take constant l's and that's
all you expect you never get angry you
just so that was just a win i was just
like i was waiting i was waiting for the
checkmate to come so i'm like you know
what as long as i keep running i was
watching the timer that's the thing my
whole thing is yeah i'm done with done
with pieces don't know where to go but
if the timer runs out they start getting
stressed um so my plan was just move a
piece that i know won't mess me up
and might throw him off and then he'll
have to think about it and his timer
goes lower that's the only way i can
play chess otherwise not i ain't good at
it nope nothing what it worked for you
minx and you know we saw you have the
voice of an angel doing or like wow we
need to get some kind of duet between
harry mack and minx going on at some
point so yes
that rap was insane at the start chad
was like your opponent's rapping and i
was like i thought they were beaming and
i went in and it was actually so good
i'm like oh i almost missed the game i
hear the piece click and i'm like wait
has the game started and i go back and
the game started i was so distracted by
your rapping oh thank you that could be
a strategy in the future that was
i'm going to use that in the future but
uh it backfired because i almost missed
the start as well i started panicking
there for a second i was so involved in
the rap i forgot that i had a bigger
task at hand here today so
we were oppressed our mouths were just
dropping open so thank you for that as
well harry no my pleasure
well harry i'm sorry you had that tough
loss but you are playing incredibly for
the amount of time you've been playing
chess we can tell that your you know
freestyling skills are actually
translating to chess because you're a
very quick thinker and minx you came in
you won you were the underdog and you
won some people in chess.com chat so
many free points so shout out to them
and congratulations minks we appreciate
both of you so much
thank you thank you thank you for having
us and harry i will say you were i best
opponent i will ever have uh same vibe
and save mental length uh
good luck in your future games yes same
to you same to you we'll have to uh play
each other again sometime yes definitely
all right thank you so much
what a match it was alexandra incredible
stuff it really was and it would not
have been possible without the pogchamps
for sponsor coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase and this is actually the same
place i made my first crypto purchase or
if you're an experienced trader
coinboy that's awesome coinbase has you
covered get exclusive rewards when you
spend with the coinbase card and much
more and if you visit coinbase.com chess
you haven't used it before you'll get
five dollars free in bitcoin when you
sign up and verify your account
so without further ado we will be back
very soon with the last match up of the
day box box versus sapnap don't go
anywhere
uh we've got
we've got a line here
[Laughter]
sack the queen it's been an honor
smothered me
i see this ever on reddit
that specific line where you just go
like queen sack into night
i can recognize the queen sack from a
billion miles away wait is this the
greek guy
check
no i don't think this is a greek guy
game
all right
uh he also has like a big nasty thing
here
is it ever the defensive play no it's
not i would lose it i would hang my
bishop there
okay so i'm about to get uh we
could do this as a defensive play but i
think that's
[Music]
kind of bad but like it's a chess puzzle
and there's no way the defensive play is
the correct move i feel like every chess
puzzle is to find the offensive solution
but
all right that's not how you should look
at it in a real game
oh i was wrong
[Music]
hmm
what
all right just tell me the answer i'm
too dumb to see it oh what the hell
oh
i see i see this is better because it
now he can't just move the pawn to
defend and when he moves up oh
my god
how do people see these
okay okay albert box boxing treat this
as if it was pog champs
okay what do i see i'm down in material
but his rooks are not connected with
this king uh i on the other hand have
some sort of offensive potential here
let's let's let's count the squares
so this square is cut off it's cut off
cut off
if i were to go here i would then cut
off this square
you'd have to go to one of these two and
then i could go
[Applause]
okay so he's definitely going to he's
definitely going to this square right
here
oh my god is that actually i mean
oh i'm wrong i'm wrong because if i do
that i no longer no longer cover this
square if you can go this way
hello kirito
oh so i go i go underneath them
okay it's the same concept if i go
underneath okay
we were close
so
what happens here i it's definitely this
that's the correct move because he
cannot defend against it he has to keep
moving and i get to play around with him
uh then i check
then i check
oh i blended my queen then i check
okay
that one i probably have to spend like a
full minute on in a real game make sure
i don't screw that up
okay albert
focus on the match pretend it's the real
thing
okay you cannot take this with your rook
because then you drop
you hang mate in one
you can take this with the queen and
then everything protects each other
uh but then he's gonna go here no he
can't even
what
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on
eternal
collecting these sometimes hilarious
always epic gaming and irl highlights
directly benefits the creators while
providing you the fans something unique
and special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
welcome back to pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase and uh before we get into our
final match of the day
between box box and sapnap let's have a
quick look at the prizes here
and man twenty thousand bucks for the
winner we've got
lots of prizes a hundred k prize fun
total
alexander lots on the line here for the
players obviously they're used to
playing tournaments they're used to
contesting large prizes but nonetheless
this has a special kind of ring to it
everybody's always nervous no matter how
many subs they have that's why i love it
absolutely you have something on the
line and then it just makes the
incentives feel a little bit sharper and
box fox versus savnap is going to be uh
the strongest matchup we see today
boxbox was doing puzzles he's almost at
2000 rated and i know that his rapid is
about 1200 right now but he's definitely
capable of playing in the 1400 range and
sapnap he has participated in two chess
tournaments that my sister and i hosted
for minecrafters and he's won both of
them even beating his great friend
george not found who is actually around
you know 12 to 1400 rating ability
himself so when sapnab focuses he is
very scary at chess but still he is less
experienced than box box so it was going
to be a difficult matchup for him
and we have game started all right i
don't know how much he is i was looking
for that game that final game where he
played his friend but it was not found
so
as we practiced
the standard opening practice
it's all about just don't plunder
forehead
fox loves this opening
he really does he's been playing it
since the first block champs
cover this moon
make sure that this bishop is the only
thing i can get into my face
d5 is great
the animations
mm-hmm
where i push
if i push what happens take take
no no i i lose
okay i'm pretty sure you should take
that bun yep
oh crap that already derails my plan
if he likes the center to be closed uh
what if i push then he
i push he push
box is already puzzled
he is um and and sapnap has 10 minutes
on the clock he's sitting there with all
of his time
d3 by box
now sapnap should take that pawn on e4
but he castles which is reasonable now
boxing develops his bishop to g2 that's
what he's going to do
yep and then
sapnap probably can continue with a move
like bishop e6 and
he's very focused uh you know sapnap
he's usually talking a lot more because
he's playing one of his friends who's
also talking but like we said when
sapnab gets serious his chest can get
really scary here
and it is this is a great move
look at the speed wait my letter goes
going crazy
the wheels coming off early for box box
here
oh my god um
[Music]
i don't see anywhere he can attack
though
maybe he goes here what is he threatened
nothing
he moves knight
knight c3 to b2 doesn't really threaten
anything can't move in disaster that's
tough i think that's it i think he loses
that right
i can see why you won those tournaments
yeah i mean in the early going this felt
more like a misplay on box box but
sapnap also
sees the opportunity and he saw it so
quickly he didn't miss a beat
and i want to point something out which
is that um when he played h6 to chase
the bishop away box box could have taken
the knight on f6 yep but then black
takes to the queen i don't know whether
zapnap saw that in its entirety and the
queen and the bishop attacked the pawn
enough to otherwise black would have
lost the pawn on d5 so this was a very
well calculated move by sapnap and box
bishop h4 was kind of automatic right
that's what you normally do but that
pawn on g3
uh prevents the bishop from escaping
further now he's taking a long think
trying to figure out what to do how to
get the most of the piece okay we're
going to go off the rails here
if i lose then so be it
i made that move away too fast
weenie who's actually really really good
great counter attack ideas
i'm trying to think can we at least turn
this blunder into some sort of
opportunity
the right way to think about it
yep he's going for what we call a dead
colorado
your position is worse so you don't need
to play accurately you just have to make
it as tricky it might not work but i'm
very interested in trying i can't
believe i made that bishop blender oh my
god
i played too cocky too fast
that is one of the okay if i'm good at
the game i'll make the comeback
let him take my bishop push in push push
his king is unprotected
and we can at least turn it into an
opportunity
this is the excellent thing by box box
that's the only downside of g5 is that
it weakens black's king
but zapdap should take the bishop anyway
i think he's getting a little bit
worried
about the possibility of that queen
kind of stuck in that little corner
right there and i don't like that not
trying to get mated that quick
it's just king up to g7 so that way no
i don't know what he can do here
can't take with the queen he'll i'll
take out the pawn he loses the queen
and that's the only thing that's new
positioning for moving that queen
yep bishop takes is a scary threat here
because now he gets both pawns
but he doesn't open up the g file which
is good
that's right
we might see even a perpetual check
potentially with the queen constantly
checking the king on these two files
yeah do you do you think box box should
go for that or as the higher rated
player he should try to force because he
does have a nice he'll probably play for
a win would be my guess
a queen can
so competitive people don't usually like
getting draws
no not particularly not this early
but
the issue right now is that
box only has a queen in the attack
let's see how he's thinking about it
yep one piece is not enough let's push
this knight
up hmm
[Music]
uh let me just see if there's any good
moves for him
i think this is pretty solid
the only thing is he doesn't want to
trade queens no
so if sapnap takes it the queen should
move in with a check that's called an in
between if i get my knight right here i
win the game
because that's not going to involve
black blundering queen here wins the
game
coach dania
yeah that would involve like leaving the
night
[Music]
okay fox can take that game is saved
oh no i blundered a bishop
it doesn't matter
okay hang on
before i before i take this favorable
trade
uh why until i go here there's nothing
better
no then he moves the knight back
otherwise it would be mate
yeah that was a really good call on his
part
now he wins back the night and he's got
two extra pawns but
it's an end game anything can happen in
the end game
that is true
um
so we're not gonna call anyone out
and box box is a little bit lower on
time that being said he's just so
experienced it will be an uphill battle
here for sapna but he totally still has
chances and hopefully he doesn't get
down on himself after dropping that
piece
yeah i i think he got really excited but
box queen d2 that was a key that was an
early important moment because it posed
a lot of practical challenges for black
it's so down into sapnap's mind
and the knight
confidently drops back to d5 now he's
threatening another pawn
things are looking pretty grim here for
sapnap who gives a check on b4 yeah
boxing cover it with c3 he can take that
bishop anything is good here
right um just trading off being two
pawns up is more than enough um
i like c32
like you said it's all
gucci for box box here
oh absolutely sapnap i guess he's gonna
have to try to develop his bishop bring
his rook into action um and just try to
be on the defensive and hope that box
box ends up getting in some kind of time
pressure or just wait for any kind of
mistake but instead he plays bishop c5
oh no
offended
now he's down three puns but in a funny
way the position's not entirely decided
yet box will have a hard time bringing
the rest of his pieces out he should
patiently bring the bishop out to g2
that's the next step if your box box
but i i'm afraid he might
castle
or
start pushing his pawns but we'll see
yeah although box box
is a pretty principled player so bishop
d2 is definitely in his range of moves
that he would play
oh yeah but f4 i actually don't mind
um no that's not a bad move oh wow okay
and uh
six might be playing a little bit too
quickly i think that may have been his
downfall he did speed through this
yeah it seems like that moment after
knight d5 was played he reacted very
quickly trying to attack the queen
without realizing that the queen could
actually grab the knight right and box
pushing the pawn out to f5
which is reasonable locking up the
center here that gives him more time to
bring pieces out
yeah um and he's got only one pass spawn
even though he's up two pawns so the
fact that sapnap's pawn is on f6 might
help him a little bit or at least just
try to make box box
plan a little bit harder still his
development is going to be really really
tricky here let's make sure he moves his
rook and doesn't make a bad blunder
right he's taking a while here he should
probably move it back one square to
attack white's knight but then the
knight could drop back to d5 right and
attacked upon an f6
which black cannot afford to lose nope
that pawn is holding black's position
together here
or what remains of it yeah
hey box blocks under five minutes on the
clock now true no no absolutely
he does look very relaxed though i think
he's still
you know he's riding the high of
getting that piece back right
brook drops back to g8 next up
castle
and it's time to push
okay
okay move castling along
yes let's castle
eventually you want to bring it back out
i have a backup plan
if i if he goes here i go here and i
fork
i like the sound effects all right
that helped us understand right now
another plan is to push over here on
this front his king is very exposed
snap throwing in a check
i did not see that coming but i don't
think it matters
good
reaction think toward the center
okay sapnap is still very actually now
he can get his rook in
and the funny thing that bishop on e3 is
undefended the knight could come back to
d5 with a fork
that's true um
and then even if he defends it with
bishop g5
then box box can just push it away
and i think he's going to see that he's
good at tactics he's so good at talking
yeah there he is um that's child's play
for box he sees the stuff for
breakfast and it's not even that snap
knob is playing poorly he's just playing
somebody who's much stronger uh in terms
of chess hilo and experience he's played
for longer
and he's done so many problems he has a
good sense for the position he he knows
what's going on
he has a good instinct of identifying
weaknesses so he does all of all of the
you know good professional things and
sapnet's position is
unfortunately i'm afraid he might
blunder as bishop too because sometimes
you you get bogged down with only seeing
one
hanging piece no brought it back
the guy's good that's good no he he sees
the tactics um and now his rook and
bishop are under attack so he should
defend his bishop one way
and once box's pawns start rolling
though it's going to be a it's just
going to be a massacre
yeah it is it is kind of brutal uh but
again
he just needs one blunder from box box
to be back and if we've learned anything
today donya is that right god knows what
the results are gonna be no literally
there's no way to predict even if you
know as prophetic as one might be
yes chad is saying this is fork city
city i know it's a pretty common term
yeah i know something followed by city i
think is a pretty common way to
emphasize
the state of affairs or something yeah
absolutely
okay so sapnap's thinking
the delta between their two times is
getting smaller here which makes me a
little bit nervous because that would be
sap nap's potential trump here where
even though he's down you know if boxbox
gets low on time and wait wonders even
one piece
okay this is easy to defend what am i
doing
i thought my h6 okay he's disinserted a
little bit
all right good move 58 good defending
the bishop
a box can just trade that to simplify
and then start pushing those king side
bonds g4 h4 g5
yeah i like that plan a lot it's very
straightforward
just trades gets rid of anything
um i'm going to ask you your least
favorite question so what does sapnef do
well first you got to see what box box
does because i think he might want to
play d4 at least he was suffering an
arrow over that now he wants to play g4
if he plays g4 there's nothing you can
do is preventing my knight from playing
the game
maybe push your peep on out to b4 try to
open up
you got to try to get to white's king
somehow yep
i'm very impressed that fox is
banging in the right direction here
yeah
three and a half minutes though
i can always just hide later
such calming
music if this is something you'd hear in
like a fancy
french restaurant right
not that
i wouldn't what a fancy french
restaurant looks like
daniel's regular wednesday
right my wednesday you know my casual
one wait what if i push the plug instead
yeah
exactly
yeah then my king okay it's always
i like what sapnap's trying to do
that's a great move on his end and this
pawn dominates the knight prevents him
from getting two good squares
this is a pretty good pretty good music
to take a nap too
unusual but is it making me sleepy
it's very sappy
it's true
okay this is a completely failed attempt
at a fun i was trying to capture both
words in one sappy and nappy no no you
got them in two sentences i think it
worked out um oh thank you
okay so 97 retreating
i mean again there's not a ton of good
moves here at least he activated all of
his pieces maybe sabnaf can try to fling
some pawns over like b5 and b4 just
create complications try to get box box
low
on the clock if he comes back from this
somehow it'll be incredible it looks
like he's saying something actually
sapnap
yeah and box could be on knight g4 here
and black spots are like
i respond to like george washington's
teeth
okay what does he want to do there i see
let's just get this knight out of here
take the bishop and go g4
yep
i'm going to arrow it out there
this would be a great plan for box box
box box is taking a lot of time he is a
bit rusty
okay
box box sees it of course he does
to elaborate on my comparison i just
mean to say there's not a lot of them
left not a lot of bonds
chat
chat yups
yeah
yep champ
three head
okay so the pawns are being pushed
sabnab's king is really uncomfortable
right now i don't like what's going on
there sapnap i think it's it's time for
him to throw rocks at his opponent
and hope one of them no you gotta do it
that's absolutely right meanwhile i've
been thinking about like what's the
classic fancy french restaurant dish and
i came up with escargot
oh have you had us
i think only once but
do you know the joke uh why did the why
did the man paint
the letter s on all of his cars
the word yes
okay
so something to go with on his car on
his car cargo
um yeah he wanted he wanted to see the
escargot
okay
good one
i mean
this is why they invite me to pogchamps
you don't understand
but we're just watching boxes boxes
pawns go
i mean
again box box is just playing this so
well the pawns are coming and and poor
sapnap is trying to survive this but
he's outnumbered it's a sparta situation
it really oh f6 is coming in oh man time
to make some kebabs out of black's
pieces yeah i think we're both getting
hungry they're just awesome yeah the
food references
i've accelerated
proportionally to the time the broadcast
god-tier dad joke there you go um
yeah the the ev the eval bar
is
not too generous here either
but
again two minutes on the clock for box
box
uh
we're gonna see
sapnap sacrificing one of his pieces
here not a good situation it's like
trying to pick your favorite child which
i always win even though my sister won't
admit
um
but he's freed up his knight now so
that's good looking towards h4
and the box box has two pass pawns but
at least there are some ways to stop
them you know f7 you can block with the
rook h5 is not going to promote to h8 in
the long run well in the long run it
might but in the short term at least
there's the king vlogging
given box fox experience i'm not worried
about stalemate or anything like that
the only thing i'm slightly concerned
about about is this clock
yeah yeah his clock is the scariest of
this situation especially if he's trying
to play very accurately because you know
box box prides himself and you know
being kind of like a very good gamer so
he might take a lot of time but
still incredible comeback from his end
and he's just playing so well so
deserved so far
yeah knight h5 just the cherry on top
he's not even giving up the that uh f
pun
ah yep clock meme is back
in a while good move yup clockers
oh am i down to just take this to
simplify the game
take and then e5 oh look at those pawns
oh my god
without all of white's pieces the
position oh no i think i have to take it
maybe we just take it my night's trapped
oh it's hilarious
wow then we can go be annoying
yeah
[Music]
wow i'm so annoying with my pawns holy
crap
yeah you are actually slowly moving yeah
you have to be careful because you might
bait him into playing rookie eight and
there it is
f7
yeah
[Music]
i mean you can see how much more
confident boxes once he knows he's
totally winning and that's that's
experience right there yep
he knows he's gonna convert this
[Music]
i hope sapnab doesn't feel too down
going into the next game
no he played great
honestly it seems like he lost some
steam as the game went on but very
competitive
yeah uh well
at this point i don't know how sapnap is
gonna save it i think he's just playing
out until the checkmate but the most
important thing is that he doesn't get
tilted going into match two a lot of
players play worse the second game when
they've lost the first one there's a lot
more pressure um if he's able to keep
his cool
he had chances in this game and he's
gonna have chances in the second
absolutely it's a must win so you know
he's got a pretty big mountain to climb
but if he can repeat a successful
opening i think
the key moment in game one was when he
got scared to take the bishop he wanted
to do it on his own terms he brought his
king up he let box sack his bishop for
two pawns rather than just one
and things went downhill from there as
box is gonna make a queen and queen d6
is made in one
the box might go for that rook
which is also solid
and he's got that bishop keeping the b5
escape square
i think he should invite a maiden one
advisor harry mack to
tell him how to give checkmate wow okay
that was real yeah harry's probably
chill recovery harry harry was saying
this commentator's a nice guy oh no he
played a really good early game but we
we relied on our fundamentals and made
something happen late game
yep that is that's exactly what he did
good summary of the game in box wins the
first one
impressive stuff alexandra not entirely
unexpected and definitely very very
competitive so as you said sapnap should
keep his head up high
and and come in confident in game two
absolutely we will be back soon you guys
for match number two where we'll see
if sapnap can come back
he could have
after he trapped this bishop
gone up
this queen move was tricky but it wasn't
that devastating
um
taking isn't like the worst thing in the
world but i guess it's kind of annoying
to have a queen right here and your king
can literally not move anywhere at all
[Music]
yeah i don't i don't know
i think he over thought this section
right here
what was the best thing he could have
done right here
because what he actually did
was not the best
[Music]
i want to look at it i want to look at
it
because this is the only part where he
got
cause sapnap actually killed it dude
600 raiding his cap
[Music]
can we stop by the way
with all these lies and deceits
[Music]
all these players with their like uh i
am only 100 rated oh this is so
embarrassing
and then they're like cracked
like mr b 600 rated 20 move preparation
against me doesn't really paint the full
picture
all right what was the best thing he
could have done
[Music]
d4
push up the pod knight has to move back
you don't need to take this bishop
because there's literally no way for it
to escape
[Music]
and then get this knight out of dodge
so that the queen's now defending this
area
[Music]
welcome back to pogchamps and remember
to check out learn chess with dr wolf
the virtual chess coach which is
available now with a one week free trial
on ios and android if you're new to
chess or just need a refresh the virtual
chess coach will show you everything you
need to know it's the next best thing to
learning from a real person learn from
dr wolfe download it now
all right well i think snapnap might
need some sessions with dr wolfe
yeah
he's got a tall order ahead of him here
again i'm still super impressed with how
much zapnap has progressed with his
chest he is the underdog here i hope
that game is not getting to his head and
we're gonna see how he does in the
second game um which we are just waiting
for them to begin shortly and i love how
box box was just so respectful at the
end of the game as well
yeah and i think we see that across the
board um these players are very
competitive they're they're used to it
from what they do
uh on their streams but
uh you know they're not nasty about it
and they're incredibly gracious and that
just makes it so much more fun to watch
i think we've seen that in every matchup
so far as we see
sadness going with one to d4 yeah what
would make it less fun to watch is the
fact that andrea coached him
another london i know i wonder who
taught him itching to see another london
today
my day would not have been complete
without it and minx almost went for it i
was so excited oh and
a double london this is even better yeah
wow tears of joy is in your eyes almost
i'm
i'm getting
getting really emotional yeah
double london i've never seen such an
entertaining test right
um so bishop d3 very solid move here you
know it does make the white situation
but g6 is not what you usually see here
what do you think is going on
that's a weird move i mean it's not
usually combined with it
let's see how
i don't think so
i just know in the london i want to keep
my bishops alive for as long as i can
i'll just play passive
knight f3 is reasonable
i wonder if box will fianchetto his
bishop
why else did he play g6
yeah
box box loves the fianchettos yeah i
don't want him to take my bishop so
we'll move the h pawn up so my bishop
has an escape route
he's remembering even if not the exact
same position but he remembers the
principles which is awesome
oh my god g4
feels dangerous
g4 wins the bishop come on box
uh sorry come on zap nap see it
now actually it technically doesn't
g5 but that would be almost impossible
to find oh no no
sag
that would have been
a great opportunity for a comeback
especially as the underdog
um
go to giving him best chances so far to
equalize the match but his position is
still fine here so
yeah box is playing a weird mixture of
moves which should not
serve him very well you should just keep
developing or he can take take the
knight and take the bishop just simplify
it seems like he's less confident in the
opening which is really interesting man
whoever coached uh sapnap did a great
job
truly andrea did a great job no it was
um
the only thing that i i would hope
sapnap is careful of is to not act you
know accidentally take with the knight
pawn takes and end up you know in fork
town once again
mm-hmm
he sees it he pushes chief oh my gosh
and now will box box know to take the
knight
well let's see i keep doing that yep i
keep doing that
i wondered if
well you sort of wanted a bishop but he
can save it
i keep doing that i keep plundering
bishops
training yes he sees it
where'd your man go
wow
impressive
and now he should take the bishop and oh
wait suddenly it's not so lucky that
he's in one piece
there should be four it's a pretty high
level move trying to go here
or do i want to go trade
yeah i
mean again i'm pretty sure i want to go
here
his tactics are just super sharp yeah
they are
you know he almost never blunders in one
move so that last game was very rare
yeah
to beat box box you need out you need to
outplay him like you gotta
really see more than he sees throughout
the game
he rarely gifts it to anybody and i like
the way sapnap reacted to that takes in
centralizing his knight and
if a move like f6 ever happens his
knight always has that c4 escape square
unless he ends up making a move like c4
so you'll have to be careful to make
sure not to put a pawn on his knight's
main escape square here that's the only
thing that i could see being kind of
tricky about what he did here
yeah that's a that's a good point that
knight is
a little bit short of squares so
box could play knight d7 you could
castle
but he shouldn't do anything crazy here
until he's finished his development
yeah absolutely it's always best to well
not always it's never always in chess
but if you're relatively new get your
king to safety develop your pieces and
it's just gonna help you improve so much
faster at the start it'd actually be
really cool if foxbox ends up castling
but sapnap doesn't and he counts castles
the other side and tries to go for an
attack i would love to see that i would
love to see that as well that would be
quite rare in london
um
the fascinating opening that it is
to see um opposite side castling
hey it is your favorite opening for a
reason
exactly
box is taking a long time and and
it's interesting this happened in the
last game but
but eventually uh box kind of sped up
here he's really sinking into that clock
down to six and a half minutes could be
concerning
it could be concerning um
although in the last game no he didn't
get into time pressure yet because he
had a game that was just pretty
straightforward to play
and queen h4 looks a little bit
concerning here doesn't do anything that
queen alone is only going to get it get
itself in trouble yeah because g5
potentially just trapping the queen on
h4 for a little bit maybe that's not the
best move but he also has ideas like
queen before to attack the pawn on b7
and keep the king from castling queenie
two
doesn't do anything but i think he's
trying to go for queen b5 so he he had a
similar idea just misplayed it slightly
so box needs to castle he just doesn't
seem concerned enough that king in the
center as you said queen before oh my f5
is a terrible move he's not sensing the
danger at all all right 85 is totally
winning come on sapnap
why else did he play queen e2 but is he
gonna get distracted that's my worry
that sat nap gets distracted castle here
now box has to castle get my rook out
connect the rooks
looks good
you need to think bigger he's being
principled
but i thought that he played queenie too
because he saw the idea i'm going to
blame that on his coach
oh she's really getting all the blame
i want to win
how do i win this how do i win this come
on
you made him brain show me the chess
moves
show me the chess moves
do i need to like take bills like the
one and one girl in
taking a long time again he's down to
five minutes
this
game has not gone his way he just sees
the castle he's overthinking this
biology okay now now jesus oh my god
queen trap or knight takes g6 i mean
anything that's clear
but g5 is even better because it just
wins the queen
oh my god that's a big box box is
playing
this second game worse than his first
game
i think maybe he got overconfident oh no
oh no
well still queen b5 is gonna be
devastating but i don't think he's
looking
past the fourth rank i think he's trying
to get all his pieces in
oh i guess now that i think about it am
i even going to look at the other side
yeah
box is going off the rails here he's
tinkering with the king's side when his
kingdom's on fire
that's that's a good
am i even winning
for what's going on
[Music]
but box box is so low on time here yeah
he is he might just lose this game on
time if he doesn't
yeah this is totally like position is
still going to be here he recognizes it
somebody in chat said this is not a fair
matchup
no are you kidding savnab is over
performing and making this more fair
than we expected free
i think i like it yeah
essentially checkmate where does he go
you can't go here
oh
that is a very very bad move
queen b5 oh my god it would have been so
beautiful but he's just winning on the
spot
and now it's uh we have some moves here
now this is much more of a game than the
last game what's the next move
he's not too upset but i don't think he
realizes how close he was to just
winning out right right i feel like
he do what can he do he pushes this it
doesn't work pushes this it doesn't work
all because
yeah i think i can push this
take and i get that it's a great move or
yes
black wins a piece with an f4 but that's
really hard to see
how do i win this how do i win how do i
win how do i
it's so sharp
if he sees that four
then he's the deserving winner yeah i'm
going to arrow it out the thing is the
reason why it's so important is because
it also clears it up for the rook
i think he's seeing it oh my gosh
oh my god he's calculating it
and he's about to play it he's done it
insane
and the move looks scary but
remember like what does he drop
all those tactics alexandra i know
they're paying off i mean what's
impressive also does a lot of tactics
i'll get that in a bit not during the
game
he's getting sub bomb thank you though
[Music]
the sapnap stop bombing
right
he's trying to get him to not see the
knight on e5 so now sapnap loses a piece
great concept to open the center but he
should have done that with the queens on
the board yep
okay so now sapnap is going to be down a
piece after the trade but boxbox's
pieces are still not developed um
he has a pass pawn and he's up four
minutes on the clock still now very
favorable for box box but there are
chances
the problem is also that box only needs
a draw
although
as we know draws are
the fact that we've seen two draws today
is
yeah the draws on her
are not really you know theoretical
draws where they're like yeah let's take
a draw
i'm sure alexander you have your pro
you have your story about you know
seeing somebody stalemate in a
scholastic tournament and crying
i've always seen kids get overconfident
thinking i've got or like trying to make
as many queens as possible and
stalemating by accident that's true i i
remember i used to cheese my opponents
i'd get so upset if they didn't resign
that i just promote all of my pieces and
just stare at them waiting
um
but yeah i i grew up
why would anyone commentate with such a
person i i don't know danya maybe that
person has no choice but
okay sabnab also has no choice here he
is pushing his pawn you
know this pawn oh my god watch him take
take take and another back rank no not a
back rank but you'd get the knight he
would get the knight that's an amazing
move h6 and box is going to burn some
clock here figuring out how to stop the
pawn it's not funny anymore after white
gets it to age seven
i love burn clock it sounds almost as
badass as burning rubber you know like
you're in a race but it's you know for
checks it's great burning clock i'm
gonna steal that from you
okay great move
and then he's got to bring the rook back
to e8
to stop brook g rook g8 is a massive
threat here
but box season i mean this stuff this
stuff is pretty basic for him uh he said
don't go rookie seven though but he is
getting sub bomb come on please work out
think
oh
zap knap so hopeful you guys
well box was about to play rookie seven
i could see him hovering over that but
clearly he's not better of it
yeah now he sees rook chief in that
oh i guess he can move
i think box is going to go rookie here
and that goes there
it doesn't work
well you guys
uh sapnap is playing against one of the
strongest people in the tournament
because unfortunately he got paired in
the same group
um
but still very much holding on
his own
except for that
and he's getting sub bumped again who is
sub bombing him
i i gotta
get on to his twitch
let me see how many um
i can't focus how many
subs he's gotten
wow i think he just got 250 subs or i
don't know i don't know it's hard to say
but it's a lot
he but he found the right move as well
but two minutes on the clock this is the
secret agent
yeah hired by sapnap this is definitely
sapnap's work exactly
so clever
he's trying to double rooks maybe box
again below two minutes now
knight back to d7 that's not great oh
and saplunder's the pawn
no yeah he really needed that pun i mean
he's probably trying to go for something
like rook g8 without seeing that black
could then retreat and put the rook back
he's trying to be tactical but at least
he's burning clock dania yeah he's
burning he's burning through it he's
burning that box is not seeing that
one hanging but knight f6 is good too
maybe i can just kick it out though
tonight i can just
also sapnap is playing so quickly as
over 80 minutes if he slows down a
little bit it's going to help him so
much holy holy wait
okay
yeah okay well we did not pay you you
need to try to contain that
one
yeah
but
it's a good attempt um hey he's bringing
this king it's an end game that's also a
good sign
okay now the clock is really concerning
for box because if you get below a
minute
you know these players even experienced
once
we've seen people lose track of their
clock like completely forget
that you're low on time box is burning
it's burning clock it's burning more
clock okay you get more intense every
time you say it and i'm well he's now
down to a minute
oh my lens
all right sapnap your rook's under
attack
um
do you think when you're down
when your opponent is down on time it's
ever helpful when you play quickly too
so that they don't think on your time
yes i think when you're losing uh you
definitely should play quickly because
then your only try is really to get your
opponent to lose on time um you're not
going to think your way out of it and i
love what sapnap is doing here getting
his king up
end games anything can happen box needs
to move his night out he shouldn't care
about the epon he should try to trade
rooks and he knows exactly what to do
grab the e-pawn now okay
[Music]
okay you know
draw still wins for box but
check he's trying to pick that pawn
obviously he might go knight h3 but king
g3 defends the pawn yeah king g3 a
little better because it attacked the
knight as well
uh bringing his own king up
he'd be interesting if box just takes on
f2
right to mix it up
gosh that is me that will be an
interesting end game
[Music]
yeah box is handling this very well
he's going to win that pawn
yep he's doing a great job okay i win
the point he was happy to see f5 because
now that is the sitting dog
[Music]
oh my goodness
somebody's going crazy on his channel oh
god
yeah i was checking
oh my goodness
yeah that guy gifted another 200 subs
okay so somebody's gifted 450 subs i
think either a really big box box fan or
a really big really big sapnap fan yeah
unfortunately
at this point
no
even an apocalyptic event would not
deter boxbox from winning this
that is a uh
dark way to put it daniel he's gonna
start drawing chances though draw yeah
but uh yeah yeah well yeah right well
well i'm right
so i mean yeah
but honestly box box played so well and
his tactics are just unmatched from what
i've seen so far as we saw almost 2 000
rated in tactics um it's just really
hard to compete sapnap heavy underdog
winning the ninth though
tonight
oh wow boxing managed to
yeah now i mean again it's it's act
purely academic because even a draw wins
the match but what a what an effort by
sapnap let's not underestimate
everything i love those people you use
academic as having no impact on the real
world
that's what they say at the end of
basketball games right or they say
cosmetic
yeah yeah academic is more funny i
appreciated that one
um
but okay so box box still winning here
if he only had the eight pawn then it
would be a draw
um
[Music]
if he only had one punch yeah at this
point if he only had one pawn but with
two pawns he's going to win
yeah i think at our next lesson we need
to do king and finance games he's not as
confident as i'd like him to be now he
just needs to push both of the pawns at
the same time and white's king is going
to get overwhelmed trying to stop both
of them
yep this is also good
okay now kanye won he should try one
hope for c2
i'm afraid he's going to go king c1 yeah
okay king a1 king a1
okay now we go here we go
it's not so simple after king a1
actually exactly it would have been so
tricky
okay now he's going to make two queens
if he went there i was in trouble
[Music]
yep
that is one way to do it
i wouldn't pre-move if i were him there
are ways to stalemate here
yeah but
you know
stop that bends over over 10 minutes oh
my god
yeah snap nap have it ended necessarily
a lot of time here congratulations box
box
no that was a very very smooth game
by box and um
he wins the match 2-0 which is not
unexpected he is i think the strongest
player in in this pog champs he's
he's just really good alexandra he is
he's really good
zapnap played well also just a very
tough opponent for him to go against
and i think choosing the uh play of the
game presented by eternal.ggg it's not
that easy but i'm going to have to point
alexandra to that moment when he played
f4 this game he saw that tactic sapnap
he missed some chances to win earlier
with a knockout blow
but then once we got into an end game
box all those tactics he solves f4 is
brilliant what's the idea well they're
getting rid of the defender of the
knight he takes f4 g takes f4 and look
at that rook on h5 it's joining the
attack on the night laterally it's
joining with the bishop
and after bishop takes f4 there's not
enough defenders boxbox picks off the
knight and very confidently converts his
material advantage into
a win so
great moment great tactical vision and
uh remember if you think this play
deserves to be eternalized make sure to
sign up on eternal.gg
with your twitch account and type
eternal in all caps in chat to vote the
play of the games that receive the most
votes will be turned into digital
collectibles and dropped on september
the 12th with all proceeds going to red
the charity dedicated to making mental
health accessible and of course
alexander three lucky viewers who voted
will win a free pack and we will be
announcing the winners very very soon so
make sure to join in the fun eternal dot
gg sign up with your twitch account
that sounds right and i love that
they're donating to rad we're actually
almost at 2 000
donated for today moving in towards the
end of the stream so close and uh you
know just just a quick reminder what rad
does uh they are an incredible charity
rise above the disorder and they've just
helped tens of thousands of people all
over the world receive mental health
care free of charge we know how hard it
is to have affordable and accessible
health care so on that note we are going
to take a quick break and we'll be back
with an interview between sapnap and
boxbox
[Music]
so
we are back everybody we are joined by
box box and sapnap sapnap you played
incredibly well you got paired against
boxbox who is you know one of the
sharpest tactical minds in the
tournament boxbox congratulations for
your win here um
i will say though you did make us a
little bit nervous uh with the bishop
blunders it feel it felt like you were
playing a little bit quickly in in the
games
yeah i um i blended my bishop in both
games uh
first i think zapnap had amazing early
game prep
his openings made me incredibly
uncomfortable
uh i'm really bad at seeing bishop moves
and every both times when he got my
bishop i was like
and i was like okay what can we do uh
i uh i made a huge mistake of playing a
very fast soundtrack
it encouraged me to play very fast moves
uh
i was incredibly nervous overall i was
just incredibly impressed i think he
played ridiculously impressive
yeah
definitely underrated oh absolutely and
and sapnap we we're also impressed with
their opening play particularly in game
one
uh do you feel like that moment where
you you were winning the bishop but then
bucks found a way to sack it for two
pawns did you think that you'd be able
to squeeze more out of that and do you
feel like that sort of affected your
play uh moving forward i just think i
shouldn't have been as hesitant about
taking it i think i should have just
tooken it instead of trying to defend it
because i think i think if i just took
it i lost one pawn instead of two
off the bat i think i should just take
it i was just scared about like my king
being in that corner with this queen
like i felt like something weird could
have just happened so i was a little bit
scared about it i should have been less
hesitant and just took it
it's a really tough position when your
opponent starts sacrificing on your king
but it felt like you were also playing
pretty quickly i think at the end of
game two you're over 10 minutes do you
think it's your playing style or maybe
you were nervous and moving a bit faster
than usual um it's just my playstyle
like my i don't know whenever i play my
brain just goes like crazy and i just
want to go fast but
i think if i slow down i'll be much
better because like there's some things
i could have seen there that i saw like
like a second after i would move or
something and if i just waited like
literally just another second i could uh
prevent it
well box um
things were looking a little bit shaky
in the second game but the speed of
which you found that move f4 once you
enter the end game super impressive how
much do you feel like solving tactics
plays a role in your training routine do
you feel like that's
one of the things you look to when
uh when the game is uncertain your
tactical ability
uh uh
i uh i do chess.com puzzles every time i
go to the bathroom for like the last
year
wow so
my in terms of like time spent on chess
it's like ridiculously all on the
puzzles so late game it's very fun to
like uh just like say like okay this is
a chess puzzle what's the move uh so
like you probably saw like i took i took
forever on some moves
uh those are the parts where i'm telling
myself like yep it's a chess puzzle uh
go ahead and find the blender and there
wasn't always one but occasionally there
was like a cool tactic where i could
like fork something or force something
like two moves down the line uh i'm
really bad at openings
so my main worry was just like can i get
through the opening without blundering
and i blundered my bishop twice uh
i also
i was incredibly scared uh up until
like
i want to say like up until it was just
pawns left uh he had zapnap had a
massive threat i almost made the rook
blunder
but he had like two rooks and a pawn
pressed into my face
and i uh i like almost made i almost
brought my rooks to the second rank
right
but this was actually really sick um on
stream earlier i was doing puzzles and
there was like a specific there were
specific puzzles with uh the rook coming
down with the pawn and creating like
this weird diagonal thing where you're
forced to trade rooks and then the pawn
takes afterwards and i was like this is
literally exactly like the puzzles and
then it felt very comfortable again
sorry what your your bathroom puzzles
have been paved right paying off i saw
that you're almost at 2000 which was
incredible and even if you missed a
couple tactics during the games it
seemed like when you needed to focus you
would really see it which was super
impressive and then sapnap on your end
you know you had winning chances in both
games even though you were outmatched by
you know several hundred rating points
so that was really impressive um you
know box box you're definitely one of
the favorites for the entire event
sapnap you're a favorite to get into the
championship bracket best of luck to
both of you for the rest of the event
excellent match thank you thank you guys
fox
wow
alexander we got what we signed up for
three incredible matches as we have a
look at
uh the respective four groups and the
point totals for the players and of
course box box leading group b
uh lied mr beast so many names but a lot
yet to be decided
absolutely these are some really stacked
groups and we also have stacked matches
tomorrow it is gonna be super
entertaining in group d we're gonna have
puns playing against i am chris tini
then we're gonna have fundy versus cutie
cinderella they're pretty close in
raiding ludwig versus jake and bake jake
and bake is a newer player but he was
you know around a thousand rated at
chess when i chess when i uh played with
him when the first pog champs was out so
he could actually give ludwig a run for
his money and then mr beast versus five
up any thoughts there
well i'm always gonna have to go with
the more experienced player i think
they're the favorite mr beast i'll be
watching that match lud
well lud's just a beast and
you know he's gotten better and better
and better he's a force to be reckoned
with so jake and bake will have it cut
out for him and of course fundy against
cutesy
that's going to be interesting too qt
has done so well
and she's also shown some great
improvement great progress which is
always lovely to see so you're in for a
treat tomorrow
and these are going to be some
fascinating matches but now the time has
come to announce yesterday's winners of
the play of the game presented by
eternal.ggg these are the winners of
yesterday's
pogchamps matchups and in match one we
have big diesel mystique dutch brat
match two taking home the gold kale the
noise tanner b2 e938 penguini g and in
match three we have mitchell 785 c22
tech fish and 52.
um
hebrew letters and a six two five taking
their bacon wow yeah they're all
receiving one free pack of awesome
moments from pogchamps four courtesy of
our friends at eternal that is amazing
and um hey if you guys are watching and
you really enjoyed the chess and you
want to play as well you're inspired i
know when i watch chess i want to play
as well well the coinbase community cup
is where you can prove it you can get in
on the action for awesome prizes and it
doesn't matter what your chest strength
is
you can play you'll be paired against
people so similar similar levels the
arena's running every day during
pogchamps for use the command coinbase
cup in the chat for info on how to join
in
now let's get back
to us for that final sign off um
actually my sister is going to be
streaming on our channel so if you're
watching on twitch
uh
or maybe
never mind uh
i i may have mistaken the raid
daniel uh
any last words from you
well we had such a fascinating day we
had three great matchups they're always
close and the the motto anything can
happen in pogchamps
well that was proven once again but uh
that those three hours went by so fast
and uh in large part due to a great
commentator so thank you alexandra it
was it was a pleasure commentating with
you and of course everybody in the chat
cheering along
uh all these players who are putting
everything out on the line so what a day
yes and hang around you guys we're
actually rating the the chess bras today
so they will be doing some really
entertaining stuff i'm sure um on that
end on that note thank you so much for
everybody who watched and daniel it was
a pleasure doing commentary with you
today
thank you bye everybody
[Music]
so
you